MonkaW! MonkaW!
So, Chat, hab ich irgendwas Wichtiges verpasst die Woche?
War irgendwas? Ich suche ja immer noch eine gute IT-News Weekly-Zusammenfassung,
aber das scheint es ja nicht zu geben. Und die, die es gab, sind teilweise auch
wieder eingestellt. Also nicht teilweise, SIND wieder eingestellt. Ach Quatsch, ich
will das ja nur konsumieren, ich will das ja sicherlich nicht selbst schreiben, weil
ich krieg gar nicht genug mit, dass ich sowas selbst machen könne. News-Jam. Es gibt ja
schon so ein paar Versuche, solche News-Zusammenfassungen per AI zu machen. Ich hab schon ein paar Versuche
gesehen, aber das ist auch nicht so das... Ach guck mal, Microsoft hat sich ja dazu geäußert.
Interessant, das hab ich noch gar nicht gesehen. Guck mal, Microsoft hat sich dazu geäußert,
wie es jetzt aussieht mit ihrem Master-Key oder mit ihrem Master-Signing-Token, was geklaut
wurde. Das hab ich gar nicht mitbekommen. Wahrscheinlich wird Microsoft das ein bisschen
runterspielen und sagen, oh ja, na, ist gar nicht so schlimm, gar nicht so wild. Was
sagen sie denn? Microsoft hat ein Playbook zur Vorgehensweise bei... Bla bla bla bla bla
bla. Das Playbook... Könnte es auch Anleitung nennen oder so, aber nein, Playbook ist einfach
viel nicer. Okay, Microsoft selbst sagt gar nichts. Sie sagt, wir sollen ihr Tool nehmen,
was dann irgendwelche Logs überprüft und so. Naja. Genau, bislang ist das genaue Ausmaß
jedoch unklar, weil Microsoft wenig Informationen zu dem Vorfall heraus... Ja, super, ich dachte
damit kommen die jetzt endlich mal um die Ecke, aber nein, machen sie nicht. Und man
kann von einer Sache ausgehen. So große Läden wie Microsoft, wenn die die Klappe
halten zu so einem Vorfall oder erstaunlich die Klappe halten, dann ist meistens irgendwas
im Argen. Weil, wenn es größere Sachen sind, die easy gehandelt wurden, dann machen die
immer ein riesen Marketing-Tamtamtropf. Ich erinnere euch mal daran, letztens hat Microsoft
doch wieder gepostet, größter DDoS-Angriff der Geschichte abgewehrt. Nur bei Azure seid
ihr so gut geschützt und unsere Leute sind so feifertig und was wir alles machen und
hat alles wieder wunderbar. Also, ihr könnt davon ausgehen, wenn alles gut funktioniert
hat, dann ist Microsoft oder nicht nur Microsoft, da sind sie alle ganz vorne mit dabei, das
zu erzählen, wie geil sie sind. Wenn sie so ruhig sind zu so einem Vorfall, dann ist
das immer meistens kein gutes Zeichen. Okay, wenn man ein bisschen gefrustriert sein möchte,
dann lesen wir heiße Kommentare. Also, da wird wahrscheinlich nicht viel kommen.
Moin. Gut, bevor der Stream richtig angelaufen ist, machen wir mal eine Sache, die wir sonst
auch Sonntags immer machen. Wir gucken uns mal eine Runde die aktuellen Shithub-Trends
an und stellen fest, dass wahrscheinlich alles wieder AI, AI, AI ist und ein bisschen Krypto-Zeug.
Was? Oh, die Musik ist auf einmal instant so laut. Was ist denn jetzt los? Oh, ist ja
nicht richtig abgemischt, die Playlist. Das geht mir immer auf den Keks, wenn die Musik
so unterschiedlich laut ist. Was war eigentlich dein Abschlussprojekt bei der Prüfung? Ich
muss jetzt noch eins ausdenken. Also, ich hab VPN gebaut. Ich hab ein Layer 2 VPN gebaut
mit OpenVPN. Also, das Ziel war, dass ich einen ein bisschen abgelegenen Standort, dort
wo das Rechenzentrum war. Also, das Rechenzentrum ist an einem ein bisschen abgelegenen Ort
im Vergleich zu dem Hauptstandort. Und dort gab es Telefone, die mit der Telefonanlage
verbunden werden sollten. Und dann hab ich ein Layer 2 VPN gebaut, dass die Telefone
quasi einfach nur an den richtigen Switch stecken muss. Und dann booten die und ziehen
sich alles, weil sie ja quasi das gleiche machen können, wie wenn sie hier direkt
am Switch im Haus hängen würden. Ja, hab ich gemacht, aber ich hab das Projekt, also
ich hab das Projekt dokumentiert, abgegeben und so, war alles wunderbar. Aber ich hab
das Projekt, also das wurde nie wirklich abschließend benutzt, was ich da geplant hab. Aber das ist
auch egal, fürs Projekt hat's getan. Also, ich hab ein VPN gebaut. So, und das Wichtigste
bei der Abschlussprüfung ist ja eh, dass du denen nicht sagst, ich baue einen VPN,
sondern, dass du sagst, ich suche eine Lösung für Problem XY. Und in einer Abschlussprüfung
kommst du dann drauf, was die beste Lösung oder die, ja, in deinem Fall die beste Lösung
ist. Muss ja nicht allgemein die beste Lösung sein. Und da musst du dann auch irgendwie
Produkte auswählen und sowas. Da steht die IHK drauf. Wenn du denen sagst, ich baue einen
VPN mit WireGuard oder irgendwas in der Richtung, das finden die doof. Du musst sagen, ich will
Problem XY lösen und dafür muss ich das und das machen. So, inklusive Produktauswahl
und vielleicht auch gucken, was das Ganze kostet und solche Geschichten. Das mögen
die. Also, wenn du, du kannst ruhig das Thema etwas offener nennen. Ja, das muss nicht drinnen
stehen explizit, ich mach exakt das und was auch nix bringt, was auch nix bringt, ist
wenn du ein easy Thema einfach nur sinnlos aufbohrst mit mehr Technik. Wichtig ist eigentlich
das von Anfang bis Ende umzusetzen mit alledem, was für die IHK dazugehört. Ja, für die
IHK gehört dazu, Produktauswahl, was kostet das Ganze, wie viele Leute brauchen wir dafür
und sowas. Weil die IHK, ich sag's, kann's ja nicht oft genug sagen, die IHK ist ja immer
noch der Meinung, dass man zur Hälfte Kaufmann und BWL-Stelzer ist, wenn man Physik gelernt
hat. Warum auch immer die das denken, ich hab das noch nie verstanden. Es könnte auch
was rechtliches sein, weil die nur kaufmännische Sachen ausbilden, was auch immer. Es ist so,
ja. Also, du darfst nicht explizit reinschreiben, ich mach exakt das, sondern du musst schreiben,
ich löse Problem XY und dann kommt man da drauf. Was hast du denn vor zu machen? Du
musst dir doch bestimmt schon irgendwas ausgedacht haben, oder? 9fap ist auch am Start. So, also,
was trendet denn heute? Twitch buggt immer noch ein bisschen, kann das sein, Leute?
Ich bin jetzt hier gerade auf meinem Vorschau-Rechner und ich fliege laufend aus dem Chat raus.
Laufend. Welcome to chatroom, welcome, das ist das fünfte Mal jetzt, welcome to chatroom. Ich
glaub, Twitch hat immer noch ein bisschen Schmerzen. Geht's bei euch gescheit? Bitte
blinken Sie jetzt zweimal, wenn's noch Probleme gibt. Also, ja. Ey, mein Chat hat sich jetzt
fünfmal neu verbunden. Läuft, okay. Vielleicht liegt's auch an meinem Browser. Aber selten,
das macht normalerweise der Vorschau-Rechner nicht. Bin bis jetzt, was? Ich bin bis jetzt
VoIP-Image, du bist der VoIP-Image-Server. Ah, nee, ich hab, du wolltest quasi sagen,
ich hab mir bis jetzt VoIP-Image-Server oder Docker-Komponente. Ja, das ist ja kein Thema
für die Abschlussprüfung. Also, erstens, ich, also, das weiß ich persönlich nicht,
was ein VoIP-Image-Server sein soll. Was für Images braucht man für VoIP? Ach,
meinst du Benutzerbilder oder so, was dann im Telefon angezeigt wird oder wie? Der Max
ruft an, das ist das. Ach so, da ist ein Komma. Nee, das ist viel zu konkret für die Abschlussprüfung.
Und Docker-Komponente ist ja ein viel zu weites Gebiet. Das ist ja eher eine Technologie als
ein Thema für eine Abschlussprüfung. Du könntest zum Beispiel so was machen wie,
ja, also, so, also, musst dir ja immer so ein bisschen Story drumherum ausdenken. So,
ja, Aufgabe wird sein, die passende Lösung zu finden, wie man beim Anruf auf der, von der
Telefonanlage oder Anruf über die Telefonanlage, wie man dort aktuelle User-Images auf dem Display
bereitstellt. Ja, das könntest du als Thema nehmen. Und dann musst du halt gucken, wie das
Ganze funktioniert. Ja, ich find's auch ein bisschen ein Oldschool-Thema, aber warum nicht?
Gibt's ja immer noch. Ja, dann musst du erstmal sagen, okay, wie, wie, wie komm ich da dran? Ja,
eventuell als Anwendungsentwickler wäre das sogar ein richtig gutes Thema. Könntest du nämlich
sagen, okay, wir bauen eine Anbindung an die Microsoft Teams-AP und ziehen uns davon die
Bilder oder sowas in der Richtung. Könnte man richtig coole Sachen mitmachen. Ich würde das
nicht unbedingt dafür auswählen, was am Ende benutzt wird. Ich würde das, ich würde nehmen,
was gut in deinem Skillset ist. Also, nachdem ihr nicht viel Wolb gemacht habt, würde ich auch nicht
Wolb im Abschluss. Ich würde im Abschlussprojekt was nehmen, was du wirklich gut kannst. Ja, kennst
du dich, kennst du dich gut mit Linux-Servern aus, dann überleg dir irgendwie irgendwas, was damit
zu tun hat, kennst dich gut mit Windows aus, damit kennst du dich gut mit Netzwerk aus, dann baue
netzwerkmäßig was. Nehm fürs Abschlussprojekt irgendwas, was du gut kannst. Und dann strick dir
irgendeine Story drumherum, wofür das Projekt gut sein soll und dann mach das, was die IHK gerne
sieht. Ja, von Produktauswahl bis was es kostet und sowas. Kannst du darauf... Okay,
ich zeig mal erstmal gucken, was es ist. FaxExposed. Hört endlich auf, Fax zu benutzen. Also,
weiß gar nicht, was hat er denn? Fax ist doch einfach für viele Ämter immer noch absolut
Bleeding-Edge-Technologie. Neuere Sachen sind, sind ja nicht rechtssicher. Dann flippen die
wieder aus und nach dem Motto, oh nee, können sie uns das nicht per Fax schicken oder haben
sie keine Faxnummer? Ich find's auch bescheuert, dass in Deutschland noch so viel über Fax läuft.
Da siehst du, dass das irgendwann mal alles aufgebaut wurde, so 1980 oder so. Und ja,
das können wir tatsächlich gleich gucken. Also, ganz ehrlich, Leute, ich könnte zurzeit bei mir
noch einen Fax schicken. Ganz einfach, weil ich noch eine Fritzbox hab, über die du irgendwie,
die das ja halbwegs kann. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, hier, MajorPain, unser VoIP-Experte,
kann man über einen reinen VoIP-Anschluss überhaupt noch gescheit Fax schicken? Ich
persönlich würde ja sagen, ja, das funktioniert, weil die sicherlich irgendwelche extra Protokolle,
Sachen implementiert haben, dass die Oldschool-Leute noch Faxe verschicken können. Ich vermute mal,
dass auch Fax über den reinen VoIP-Anschluss geht, weil letztendlich ist Fax ja eine
analoge Übertragungsweise, ja? Hörst ja immer, wenn's Fax dran geht. Also Fax und Modem-Geräusche,
also das geht bestimmt auch über VoIP-Anschlüsse. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut das über VoIP-Anschlüsse
geht, aber bestimmt. Also ich könnte theoretisch noch einen Fax schicken, wahrscheinlich über meine
Fritzbox. Aber Fax empfangen könnte ich theoretisch auch. Ich hatte mir ja vor einer
Weile so einen, ähm, Moment, muss mal kurz bei Amazon gucken. Ich hatte mir ja vor einer Weile
einen BrotherMFCL3750CDW, übrigens bester Produktname ever, ja? Da saß in der Marketing-Abteilung
jemand, hat sich gedacht, ah, Jungs, wir haben einen neuen Drucker. Ah, wie können wir den denn
nennen? Und dann hat dann jemand gesagt, easy, MFCL3750CDW ist doch klar. So ein geiler,
griffiger Name, da wissen alle sofort Bescheid und jeder will den haben. So, und der hat noch
einen Drucker. Ja, genauso wie Waschmaschinen-Namen und sowas, das muss einfach kacke sein. Oh,
guck mal, die Brother-Seite ist down. Was ist da los? Ne, die ist einfach nur langsam. Die ist
nicht down, die ist langsam. Ja, und guck, der hat noch einen Fax. Guck hier, Druckfunktionen,
drucken, kopieren, scannen und faxen. Machst du faxen? Der hat sogar immerhin, Leute, USB 2.0.
Gut, mehr braucht er auch nicht, da kann er halt die eingescannten Bilder auf dem USB-Stick speichern
und sowas. Da siehst du, das ist die Druckertechnik, ist alles schon ein bisschen älter. 100 Base,
WLAN, BGN, 802.11n, das war vor 10, ne, noch nicht mal, das ist noch älter,
vor 15 Jahren oder so angesagt. Kam wann raus? Ach ne, das war schon, das war, ach ne, Moment,
das hab ich verwechselt. N war die erste Variante mit 5 Gigahertz, gell? Ja, ja, ja, ja. Okay,
das wurde vor 2009 offiziell veröffentlicht, dann hat es wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen
gedauert, bis es halbwegs verbreitet war. Also sagen wir mal, das sagen wir mal,
sind wir mal wohlwollend, sagen wir mal, 13 Jahre alt. Also man sieht schon,
das ist alles nicht so, nicht so mehr Bleeding Edge neuste Technik. Dafür kann man verwenden
Quartado Cloud Print, keine Ahnung was, das gibt es wahrscheinlich gar nicht,
hab ich schon nie gehört. Was ist das überhaupt? 2013 Google Cloud Print,
das gibt es doch gar nicht mehr, oder? Hat das Google nicht eingestellt? War ein Cloud Dienst,
ja. Google hat den Dienst zu 2021 eingestellt. Ich weiß nicht, was es darunter lädt auf der Seite,
aber das will ich erstmal nicht öffnen, auch wenn es von Google kommt. Wenn es direkt auf
Download geht, da ist irgendwas, irgendwas stimmt da nicht so ganz. So, wann das Teil
entwickelt wurde, gucken wir mal. Also es wurde getestet 2020. Guck mal einfach bei Geizhals,
seit wann Geizhals den Kram listet. Hast du Baldur's Gate schon gespielt? Ja,
so mittlerweile würde ich sagen 12, 13 Stunden hab ich schon, ja. Und es hat sich ein bisschen
bestätigt, das was ich mir im Vorfeld gedacht habe. Also es ist wirklich ein richtig nice RPG,
kann man nicht sagen. Also sollte jeder spielen, der auf RPGs steht. Aber es hat sich ein bisschen
bestätigt, das was ich mir im Vorfeld gedacht habe. Es ist kein Baldur's Gate 3, es ist vom
Stil her eher ein Divinity Original Sin 2,5, 3 und ich mag 6er Party mehr als 4er Party. Doch,
ist es. 6er Party ist einfach viel nicer. Man ist viel zu festgelegt, was man nutzen muss. Zumal
ja eigentlich zwei von den vier Party Slots schon eh Pflicht sind. Also ja, du kannst nicht so
wirklich, also wenn du das auf bisschen höheren Schwierigkeitsgrad spielst. Also es bleibt nicht
so viel Variationen drin wie im 6er Party System. Man kann das natürlich gut spielen und ich verstehe,
warum sie nur ein 4er Party System genommen haben. Einfach, weil es wahrscheinlich einfacher zu
designen und zu balancen ist. Aber 6er Party ist besser gewesen. So, seit wann listet denn
Geizhals den Drucker? Seit 2018. Alter, warum ist der so teuer geworden? Guck mal hier,
zwischendurch. Ist übelst hoch gegangen. Lul, jetzt geht's wieder runter. Hä? Ach so,
wahrscheinlich die übliche Technik Komponenten-Knappheit und so hier. Ja und der hat immer
noch einen Fax, der Drucker. Ich könnte Faxe empfangen und Faxe schicken. Das Ding ist halt
die, ich glaube meine Fritzbox könnte theoretisch auch. Ich glaube Fritzbox können Faxe empfangen.
Ich habe den analogen Stecker gar nicht mehr in dem Drucker drin. So, dann lass uns mal kurz
gucken, was trendet denn auf Shithub die Woche? Devops Exercises. Was gibt's denn da?
Devops Exercises. Okay. Leute, das ist glaube ich gar nicht übel, das Repo. Vielleicht können
wir uns da ein bisschen Inspiration für den Stream holen. Was gibt es denn für Exercises? Lass
uns mal gucken. Linux Master Application. What the fuck? Ja gut, das ist jetzt ein Exercise für
CP. Naja gut jetzt. Wir wollen es jetzt ja mal nicht übertreiben. Das muss ich mir mal angucken.
Das klingt gar nicht mal so schlecht. Vielleicht können wir da ein paar Streamthemen uns rausziehen.
Klingt durchaus sinnig, falls da ein bisschen größere Aufgaben dabei sind. Was da so
beispielsweise beim Thema Google Cloud drin steht. EM Roles, Compute Engine. Da steht nicht so
wirklich viel. Shithub Exercises. Naja, hält sich doch alles sehr in Grenzen, oder? Ich meine,
das ist ja schon recht übersichtlich. Aber es gibt ein paar Fragen. Ja, ich muss mir das mal
angucken. Audio AI Zeug. AI, AI. Weißen Lernzeug, AI. Keine Ahnung. Rust, blazingly fast. AI, AI, AI.
Message Queue. Warum? Blazing. Moment. Jetzt komme ich mir aber verarscht vor. Warum gibt es Blazing
MQ? Und warum ist das in C++ programmiert und nicht in Rust? Was ist das? Das ist ganz schön
Debate. Die sollten verklagt werden, dass die sich so nennen. Krastentiere United. Wie kann das sein?
Die dürfen sich nicht so nennen. Blazingly fast hätte ich jetzt gedacht. Das muss in Rust
programmiert sein. Warum ist das ja zu viel geiler als alles andere? Na gut, wenn sie meinen. Das ist
richtig. Das denke ich auch. Wenn kein Rust, dann kann es auch nicht Blazingly fast sein.
Das ist nicht gestattet. AI, AI. AI. China Chinesen, AI. Passwort Manager. Ich habe
in einem Video drüber geguckt. Das ist Form Validation für Typescript. Ich weiß auch nicht,
warum es ja immer 1030 Milliarden Libraries verbraucht. Naja, diese Woche gar nicht so viel
AI. Was ich für meine Linus VM verwende? Ich benutze VMware Workstation. Dieser Stream ist
agil. Der ist immer agil. Der ist spätestens agil, seit wir aufgehört haben, horizontal und
vertikal zu skalieren und das Ganze nur noch diagonal machen. Weil dann hat man zwei auf eins
und viel agiler geht eigentlich gar nicht mehr. Okay, ich benutze VMware Workstation und,
und by the way, ich benutze, sollte ich vielleicht auch noch mal erwähnen an der Stelle,
ich benutze Arch Linux. So, ja, VMware Workstation kann ich auch nur empfehlen,
VMware Workstation zu benutzen. Du kannst natürlich auch VMware Player oder Virtualbox oder sowas
benutzen, aber vom Gesamtpaket, ich persönlich finde VMware Workstation einfach am angenehmsten.
Das ist mir jetzt zu harte Kost. Wie lange geht der Talk? 36 Minuten. Ach, mal gucken.
Arch ist nicht outdated. Arch ist immer noch das Beste. Eventuell lasse ich mir auch gefallen,
wenn einer Gentoo by the way used. Er muss dann für den E-Mail Anhang mit Word Dokument,
sowas kommt ja immer noch vor, erstmal zwei Stunden Open Office oder LibreOffice kompilieren,
aber immerhin. Das letzte Mal, als ich Virtualbox benutzt habe, war das nicht nennenswert,
zumindest hier so vom normalen Handling nicht nennenswert, langsamer und schlechter als
VMware Workstation, aber ich finde VMware Workstation von der Bedienung und vor allem,
wenn man 3D-Sachen, also OpenGL-Sachen anzeigen lassen will, um Längen besser als Virtualbox.
Auch von der Kompatibilität her für grafische Ausgaben. Also, ich finde es lohnt sich,
VMware Workstation zu kaufen, zumal man ja auch für einen Apple und ein i schon Keys bekommt
bei Keyshops. Ne, tatsächlich nicht. Also, Multicloud-Umgebung entfernt von mehrere Sachen
für, ich sag mal so, mehrere Teile eines Services in unterschiedlichen Cloud-Umgebungen laufen lassen,
das schon, aber so Identity-Management übergreifend, keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung. Also,
auf der letzten Arbeit haben wir hauptsächlich Azure benutzt, da war es Azure, ja war es zum
größten Teil Azure AD und alles was Azure bietet in der Richtung und jetzt beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber
benutzen wir hauptsächlich Google und da ist es Google IAM. Aber, das irgendwie Cloud-Übergreifend
zusammen, ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass das wirklich Probleme macht, weil du hast viele
Features, zum Beispiel, ja, du kannst zum Beispiel bei Google relativ schön deine, ja sowas hier im
Prinzip, ja genau, du kannst zum Beispiel bei Google relativ schön konfigurieren, deine Kubernetes
Service Accounts, was die für Rechte haben, weil du die verbinden kannst mit einem Google Service
Account und solche Geschichten und die haben beispielsweise auch für ihre SQL-Server, also
für ihre Datenbanken bei Google, bieten die eine Proxy an, den kannst du relativ easy als Sidecar
in Kubernetes betreiben, der macht dann für dich Authentifizierung, ne nicht Authentifizierung,
aber gucken ob du da, ob du dahin darfst und der, der bastelt ja auch den Connection String für die
Datenbank zusammen, so und das ist natürlich ganz eng verzahnt mit dem Google IAM. Also sprich, ich
wüsste nicht, wie man diese Sachen wirklich gescheit verheiraten, weil die Cloud-Hersteller
wollen das ja auch nicht, die wollen halt, dass man ihren Shit benutzt. Das Einzige, was mir
einfallen würde, ist halt, man nimmt irgendwas Übergreifendes und dann so das kleinste gemeinsame
Subset raus. So ja, man macht ein Azure AD oder sowas und dann versucht man alles darüber, aber
ich, also keine Ahnung, kenne ich mich nicht gut aus, was hier, also was hier möglich ist. Ich stelle es mir
bloß kompliziert vor. Ja, die Cloud, die, aber das bringt dir ja alles nix, wenn du dir ein cooles
Produkt aussuchst dafür, wenn es die jeweiligen Anbieter und die Tools darauf nicht gescheit
unterstützen. Mit dem Google SQL Proxy, den wirst du nicht an Keycloak angebunden bekommen. Der kann
Google-Sachen und sonst nix. Du kannst dir sowas selbst bauen im Endeffekt dann, ja. Aber umso mehr
man selbst baut, umso mehr stellt man ja irgendwo auch in Frage, warum man überhaupt seine Sachen
bei einem Cloud-Anbieter hostet. Das ist sowas, was mir auf der Arbeit, dort, wo ich aktuell bin,
bisschen auf den Keks geht. Wir machen immer so Spezial-Dinger, anstatt einfach das zu nehmen,
was der Cloud-Anbieter hat. Wo ich mir denke, ey, guck mal, zum Beispiel, Beispiel dafür, Beispiel dafür,
ja. Wenn du ein Kubernetes-Cluster bei Google aufsetzt, kannst du den Google Ingress benutzen.
Fertig. Eigentlich relativ easy. Google Ingress, das ist schon, ist unter der Haube, glaube ich,
auch ein Nginx. Fertig. Aber nein, wir benutzen den Google Ingress nicht. Wir benutzen ein
installierten Nginx Ingress. Es hat keinen wirklich großartigen Sinn, nur dass irgendjemand mal
entschieden hat, Google Ingress wollen wir nicht benutzen. Ja, aber das bringt dir doch nix, wenn
das jeweilige Tool von Google ist und nur Google-Sachen unterstützt. Da kannst du zwar
Keycloak nehmen oder du kannst Azure AD nehmen, das bringt dir aber nix, wenn das jeweilige Tool
nur Support für Google-Sachen eingebaut hat. Der wird nicht auf magische Art und Weise LDAP oder
Keycloak können. Das machen die Cloud-Anbieter halt gerne. Also die Cloud-Anbieter sind wirklich
ganz scharf drauf, dass du eben bei ihnen bleibst. Es wird ja auch immer weiter ausgebaut, ja.
Zum Beispiel gibt es Google-Config-Connector. Bin mir nicht sicher, wie lange. Das gibt es schon
eine Weile, aber das ist glaube ich erst seit ein paar Monaten oder so Open Source. Damit kannst du,
das ist eigentlich eine richtig coole Sache, damit kannst du, ich muss euch mal ein Beispiel zeigen,
ob die ein gescheites Beispiel drin haben. Alle Google-Docs sind teilweise immer so abartig.
Ja, guck, da kannst du zum Beispiel in deinen Kubernetes-Configs andere Google-Services anlegen,
das ist quasi ein bisschen was wie Terraform in Kubernetes-Art und Weise. Natürlich unterstützt
das auch einzig und allein Google-Sachen. Kannst nicht sagen, ah, ich habe einen Kubernetes bei
Google, aber hätte gerne eine Datenbank bei Azure und lass die damit dann professionieren. Nee,
nee, nee, das funktioniert natürlich nicht. Dann lieber sowas wie Crossplane oder so,
wenn man das aus dem Kubernetes-Cluster raus machen will. Aber das ist halt so ein Ding,
das ist cool, dass es das gibt, weil das ist halt sehr angenehm, sowas zu benutzen dann,
aber es ist halt weiter Vendor-Login. Ich muss morgen meinen Ausbildungsvertrag aushandeln. Hast
du da Tipps? Da wird es wahrscheinlich nicht allzu viel auszuhandeln geben beim Ausbildungsvertrag.
Das mit dem Aushandeln kannst du dann nachmachen. Ich glaube nicht, dass du da so viel verhandeln
kannst. Zumal es sich ja eben relativ moderate Summen handelt. Morgen kurzes Feedback zum
Vorstellungsbericht. Ach ja, stimmt. Da war ja was. Zum Vorstellungsbericht letzten Donnerstag
als Java-Entwickler bei einer Bank. Ja, ich erinnere mich, ich erinnere mich. Springboot,
React, Postgres, Azure SQL. Du hast mich doch gefragt, ob ich da irgendwas... Warte mal,
was hatte ich dir nochmal geraten? Ich habe dir geraten, sag denen, dass Azure einen Kosten-Calculator
hat. Warst du das? Lief sehr gut, ab aller Wahrscheinlichkeit. Ja dann, ja dann. Und,
hast du das denen erzählt? Erzähl mal, hast du denen erzählt, dass du auf den Azure Kosten-Calculator
kommst, du darauf achtest und so und wie fanden sie das? Ja, jetzt wird es natürlich nochmal
spannend, dass sie dir auch ordentlich was bezahlen. Oder habt ihr euch schon geeinigt,
was es an Kohle gibt? Oder kommt das noch? Was ist denn das hier? Warum... Wait a minute,
warum kriege ich das empfohlen? Das muss ich mir angucken. Warum Google, warum YouTube der
Meinung ist, das muss ich mir jetzt angucken, weiß ich nicht. Aber Google war wichtig,
das muss ich mir angucken. Alter, es ist ja gut jetzt, es ist ja gut jetzt. Genug Empfehlungen
YouTube. Was kriege ich eigentlich für einen Schrott hier empfohlen die ganze Zeit? Gehaltstechnisch,
ja dann. GG Eats. Die Shorts, Alter. Sag mal, was sind das hier für dämliche Empfehlungen,
Alter? Kriege ich mal irgendwann was Gescheites? Okay, was hier? Das ist ja, also normalerweise...
Okay Leute, ich habe mir zu viele, wir haben uns eindeutig zu viele Resita-Videos angeguckt,
Resitas. Es ist ja hier, jede zweite Zeit habt ihr irgendwas davon drinnen. Guck mal,
es hört überhaupt nicht auf, es hört überhaupt nicht auf. Cool Tech under 50 Dollar. Da ist
wahrscheinlich nix Gescheites bei. Oder irgendwie so random 0815 langweilig ist. Sag mal, es hört
nicht mehr auf. Ich muss das jetzt anklicken und direkt wieder schließen. Dann checkt das
YouTube vielleicht. Nee. YouTube ist der Meinung, ich will mir das angucken. Und umso mehr ich das
anklicke, umso öfters kriege ich den Kram empfohlen. So, so. Dann lassen wir uns doch
mal selbst optimieren. Alter. So, was haben wir denn zum angucken? Guck mal hier. Du brauchst
nie wieder Passwörter. So einfach sind Passkeys. Ah ja, das kenne ich. Ich glaube zumindest das zu
kennen. Ist das nicht diese Zwei-Faktor-Geschichte übers Handy? Die aber nicht Zwei-Faktor-Geschichte
übers Handy ist, sondern jetzt irgendwie was ganz Neues, anderes. Aber im Prinzip ist es
Zwei-Faktor-Geschichte übers Handy. War das nicht das? Wo du trotzdem deine Passwörter bei
Google speichern musst, aber Google sagt, sie wissen die Passwörter selbst nicht. Unterstützt
fast halt keine Plattform. Ja, dann F. Okay. Ab letzten Montag beim neuen Arbeitgeber angefangen
Solution Architekt. Boah, das hat alles. Gibt es aber hier ganz advance Geschichten. Aber sieht
für mich eher nach starkem Projektleiter-Fuzzi gerade aus. Warte mal ab. Ganz ehrlich, die ersten
paar Wochen. Ich kann euch das aus eigener Erfahrung sagen. Ich habe jetzt ja auch zum
ersten April, das ist jetzt ziemlich genau vier Monate her, habe ich ja auch den Arbeitgeber
gewechselt. Ihr könnt davon ausgehen, dass der erste Monat komplett lost ist. Also ihr werdet
euch an viel neue Sachen gewöhnen müssen. Alle möglichen neuen Abkürzungen. Es reden auch alle
anders wie beim alten Arbeitgeber, so mit neuen anderen Bezeichnungen und so. Und ihr denkt euch
so die ersten paar Wochen. Wo bin ich denn hier gelandet? Spinnen doch alle, alle ganz merkwürdig.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das legt sich mit der Zeit und erst dann habt ihr so richtig den Blick drauf,
ob das jetzt eine gute Idee war oder nicht. Nach vier Monaten kann ich jetzt sagen Ja,
ich bin da manchmal. Wie war das eine gute Idee vom Gesamtpaket her? Ja, also die Leute sind
super. Wir haben jede Menge Vorteile, was Homeoffice angeht. Auch Kantine, wenn man mal
dahin muss, ist nice. Die haben sogar Kinderbetreuung am Start, wenn man Kinder hat. Kohle ist gut,
Homeoffice. Also insgesamt hat sich das wirklich gelohnt. Auch das, woran ich gerade mitarbeite,
so dass dieses Blockchain Cloud Projekt ist, ist mega nice. Also da kann ich nichts sagen. Es ist
besser als beim alten, wenn auch tatsächlich etwas anstrengender, weil man sich viel neue Sachen
angucken muss. Aber das, das legt sich ja mit der Zeit dann wieder. Umso besser man das alles kennt.
Also mach dir mal nichts draus. Warte mal ab, so den ersten initialen Schock nach der ersten Woche.
Warte mal ab so ein Monaten, dann guck mal. Und wenn das nichts ist, ich meine, du musst doch
ungefähr wissen, auf was du dich eingelassen hast mit der Stellenanzeige, oder? Ich meine,
wenn der Job mit der Stellenanzeige gar nichts zu tun hat, dann ist natürlich was anderes. Aber
warte mal ab. Warte mal einen Monat ab und dann guck dir das mal an. Es kann durchaus sein,
dass man sich erst ein bisschen dran gewöhnen muss. Ja, aber man muss ja zumindest schon im
Vorfeld halbwegs gewusst haben, auf was man sich einlässt, oder? Wenn es jetzt was komplett
anderes ist, würde ich mir auch Gedanken machen. Wachs an String erinnern, gute Idee. Richtig,
genau, das denke ich mir auch. Nach einer Woche ist man da komplett, die erste Woche ist man echt
komplett lost. So, also was sollte ich mir angucken? Hört endlich auf, Fax zu benutzen. Okay, Fax.
Also das Beste bei der Modem-Einwahl früher, kann ich euch sagen, waren immer noch diese tollen,
ich habe sie damals immer Faxgeräusche genannt, aber es sind ja gar keine Faxgeräusche. Es ist
ja eigentlich, wenn ja, wie nennt man das genau? Also wird ja quasi Binary-Zeug moduliert, glaube
ich, nennt man das, in analoge Telefon-Ton-Signale. Für alle, die das
nicht kennen, 56k Modem bei der Einwahl. Was jetzt? Ja, jetzt wird gewählt. Es ist auch noch
gute Tonwahl und keine Impulswahl. Kennt jemand noch Impulswahl, wo wir gerade bei richtigen
Boomer-Themen sind? Weiß jemand, was der Unterschied zwischen Impulswahl und, ich glaube,
Tonwahl ist, heißt das? Hat irgendjemand mal Impulswahl schon gehört? Das ist, ihr kennt doch
bestimmt noch Telefone mit so einer, also zumindest von Bildern und so, aber echte,
also Telefone mit so einer Drehscheibe und ich meine nicht Retro-Dinger, sondern welche echt mit
einer Drehscheibe. Das war noch Impulswahl, ja? Also sprich, du hast es dann hier gezogen und das
hat er gemacht. Dann wusste die, ja was weiß ich, Vermittlungsstelle oder was auch immer das da
gemacht hat, was du gewählt hast und danach gab es Tonwahl. Das ist bei den Telefonen, wo du dann
wirklich nur, wo du unterschiedliche Töne, wo es unterschiedliche Töne gegeben hat, je nachdem,
welche Wahltaste du gedrückt hast, ja. Und man konnte mit Modem auch Impulswahl machen,
man hat es dann wirklich gemacht. Das ist hier schon moderneres Modem. Beste. Jawoll. Ja,
dieser Sound, Alter. Ja, damit habe ich mich auch noch ein paar Jahre rumgeschlagen, 56k Modem-Einwahl
und damit nicht genug, wir haben sogar, ja es ist echt, ja ist auch etwas, ist auch ein bisschen
Musik in meinen Ohren. Das ist halt, da war ich noch sehr, sehr jung, als wir das am Start hatten.
Zumindest, wir haben damals sogar schon so Sachen gemacht, wie zwei Computer über ein Modem ins
Internet. Leute, NAT und Sachen einrichten war damals echt wir. Oder man hat, passt mal auf,
was es damals dann auch relativ schnell gab, es gab dann Microsoft Internet Connection Sharing.
Da musste man, da musste man, ja genau, das gibt es glaube ich heute noch, aber damals mit Windows
ME oder so war das ganz furchtbar neu, oder Windows 98, ich glaube Windows ME, das war eines
der Features damals von Windows ME und davor musste man das mit irgendwie so crappy Zusatzsoftware
machen und bei, ganz ehrlich, das war auch Müll. Ich habe damals, ich weiß noch, das erste Mal,
als ich versucht habe, meine Internet Connection zu teilen mit dem 56k Modem, war ein Kollege von
mir aus der Schule, also ein Freund von mir aus der Schule bei mir daheim, hat seinen Rechner mit
gebracht und wir haben versucht, uns die Verbindung zu sharen über meinen Windows Rechner und damals
haben wir sowas benutzt, das nannte sich WinRoot, ich habe keine Ahnung, ja genau, WinRoot Pro, das
klingt gut. Ja, ja, ich erinnere mich, so sah das damals aus, genau. Von wann, von wann ist dieses
Dokument, Leute? Steht das da irgendwo? Da brauchen wir ein paar Screenshots, gebt mir Screenshots. Ja,
ja genau, richtig, das sah wirklich aus wie 1995, es war ja auch fast 1995. Ja, so hat man dann damit
seine Internetverbindung geshared und dann kam sich richtig geil vor damit, dass das funktioniert
hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob es den Kram noch gibt. 2004, guckt euch das mal an. Ja, so ungefähr,
wobei, nee, nee, nee, das war noch früher, noch früher. Ich kann es immer daran festmachen,
Half-Life 1 kam 1997 raus, das heißt, wir haben 1997, 1998 rum Connections geshared über Modem,
dann ISDN und später DSL. Boomer Mode aktiviert. Wie, Moment, es gibt ein neues. Okay, bei der
gibt es ein neues. Aua, Clash wurde überarbeitet. Haben sie es tatsächlich hingekriegt? Wahnsinn.
Vielleicht müssen wir da auch noch mal reingucken. Aber ganz davon abgesehen, das Nächste ist ja
wahrscheinlich schon Battlefield, was ist es denn dann, 7 oder so rauskommt. Okay, also,
hört endlich auf, Fax zu benutzen. Fax exposed. Schauen wir mal. Boah, krasser Opa. Mein Opa
hätte im Leben kein Faxgerät sich geholt. Aber ich kann euch jetzt mal eine Sache sagen und die
finde ich heute auch noch relativ cool. Ich habe es schon mal erzählt. Ich war, glaube ich,
einer der allerersten hier in dem Gebiet, die überhaupt DSL hatten. Und das war ein super
abenteuerlicher Weg. Es war damals übrigens schon genauso scheiße wie heute, was Internet in
Deutschland angeht. Vielleicht noch ein bisschen beschissener, weil es komplett richtig echtes
Neuland damals gewesen ist. Und zwar, wir haben das abgeschlossen bei der Telekom und die haben
es ohne Scheiß, wir hätten das bekommen sollen und die haben es über ein Dreivierteljahr oder so,
ich weiß nicht genau, es war ewig lange, nicht geschafft das zu schalten. Mein Vater hat jeden
Tag bei der Telekom angerufen damals. Das ging so weit, dass er sogar die Durchwahl irgendwann vom
hessischen Telekom-Chef hatte. Und die haben immer versucht dann zu beruhigen, so, ja bald ist es
soweit, bald ist es soweit, bald ist es soweit. Ich habe euch die Story schon mal erzählt. Aber
das war, glaube ich, eines der einprägsamsten Momente, die ich je in meinem Leben hatte. Also
das DSL-Modem war schon lange an der Wand installiert. Aber jeden Tag war das rot. Da habe
ich sogar mal ein komplett eigenes Video zu gemacht. Altes, altes DSL-Modem. Ja, das hier,
das hier, hier, das war das noch, das richtig fette 268K, das richtig fette DSL-Modem. So,
und das hier oben, das blinkte immer für Sync und ist dann auf rot geblieben. Und ich habe das
Wochen, Monate, jeden Tag, wenn ich aus der Schule gekommen bin, habe ich auf das DSL-Modem geguckt,
weil die Telekom hat natürlich immer versprochen, ja morgen ist es soweit, morgen ist es soweit,
das haben die ein Dreivierteljahr versprochen irgendwie. Und ich habe, jeden Tag kam ich aus
der Schule und der Sync, ich habe das Modem immer rausgestöpselt, reingestöpselt, Sync, rot, rot,
rot, rot. Und irgendwann bin ich heimgekommen, nach einem Dreivierteljahr. Ich habe eigentlich
wahrscheinlich schon gar nicht mehr mit gerechnet. Und weil die Telekom wieder gesagt hat, ja,
jetzt ist es geschaltet, jetzt ist es soweit. Und dann habe ich das reingesteckt und dann ist
das Sync auf grün gegangen. DSL-Sync auf grün. Leute, das war, glaube ich, eines der glücklichsten
Tage in meinem Leben. Klingt jetzt vielleicht übertrieben, aber ist so. Es war echt eines der
krassesten Feelings, was Technik angeht, die ich jemals hatte. Als der DSL-Sync nach einem
Dreivierteljahr, nach einem Dreivierteljahr immer wieder gucken, von rot auf grün gegangen ist,
zum ersten Mal mit 768k ins Internet konnte. Ja, so viel dazu. Ich war einer der aller,
aller, aller Ersten hier in Hanau und Region, die DSL hatten. So, Fax. Warum eigentlich? Was hat Fax,
was E-Mail oder gar Gott bewahre Messenger nicht haben? Fax hat, glaube ich, wenn es um rechtssichere
Zustellungen geht, von Dokumenten immer noch einen Vorteil gegenüber E-Mail. Ich bin mir aber
nicht sicher, wie da die aktuelle Lage ist. Und warum hat Deutschland eigentlich so ein
intimes Verhältnis zum Fax? Weil die Technik aufgebaut wurde 1980 und in Deutschland sich
nichts auf die Schnelle tut. Ich finde es immer witzig, wenn sich mal wieder irgendwelche Politiker
hinstellen oder sei es auch lokale Bürgermeister und sowas, die sagen, unsere Verwaltung, in zwei
Jahren sind wir komplett digital. Es passiert nie was. Es wird immer nur gesagt, in zwei Jahren
haben wir das. Hat nicht vor drei, vier Jahren mal jemand erzählt, bis 2022 oder so soll Deutschland
die modernste Verwaltung in der EU haben? Und was ist passiert? Nichts. Der Pressesprecher hat auch
2018 erzählt, dass 50 Mbit für alle, Moment, 50 Mbit für alle, habe ich doch auf Twitter gepostet,
ist bei euch auch schon. Ja, 2017, guck mal, 2017 hat der Regierungssprecher gepostet,
50 Mbit für jeden Haushalt werden wir 2018 schaffen. Aber es ist 2023 und wir haben 50 Mbit
immer noch nicht für alle Haushalte geschafft. Das ist halt einfach so, dass so diese typische
Taktik, wir lügen, wir wissen auch, dass wir lügen, aber es ist so lange hin, dass es die Leute
wieder vergessen haben, dass wir vor fünf Jahren gelogen haben. Es ist einfach so viel Bullshit,
was da erzählt wird. Ich meine, es hat sich gerade die letzten Jahre aber, gerade die letzten Jahre,
hat sich tatsächlich, was Glasfaserausbau angeht, echt was getan und ich spüre da einen gewissen,
ja, einen gewissen Zug, was Glasfaserausbau angeht. Also da hat es die letzten Jahre mehr
getan als 15 Jahre davor, auch wenn wir hätten schon viel früher anfangen sollen. Okay, Fax.
Wo Fax noch im Einsatz ist. Sagen die Amis dazu eigentlich Fax? Wie nennen die Amis das? Ich
glaube, ich habe noch nie einen Ami Fax sagen gehört. Sagen die Fax? Fax. So ist es auch so
auf Deutsch. Na gut. Guck mal hier, das bin ich, wie ich mir ein sicheres Passwort ausdenke. Moment,
das ist das falsche Video. Kann das sein? Kegquate. Ich bin im falschen Video gelandet.
Die Technik unter euch werden sich das kaum vorstellen können, aber Fax ist wirklich noch
im Einsatz. Ja, natürlich. Auch wenn es ein Meme ist. Faxgeräte gibt es noch. Besonders im
Gesundheitswesen sind die Dinge auf Kuschelkurs. Leute, ich arbeite, also ich habe lange bei einer
Bank gearbeitet, bei einer Versicherung. Was meint ihr, was da noch an gefaxt wird? Meine
Partnerin arbeitet im Gesundheitswesen und schwärmt regelmäßig von Faxgeräten. Faxbeste. Statt einfach
den Bericht wie jeder normale Mensch mit dem PC zu schreiben und kurz rüber zu senden, nehmen
manche Ärzte gerne einen Wisch und schreiben da in ihrer schönsten Sonntagsschrift das genaue
Leiden des Patienten drauf, damit es untersucht werden kann. Zwischenstationen, die Befunde. Jeder
hat das Recht. Er möchte nur per Fax kontaktiert werden und dann müssen alle anderen dieses Fax
auch als Kommunikationsmittel nehmen. Auch viele Anwaltskanzleien nutzen gerne ausgesuchte Dokumente,
denn nur was man anfassen kann, das ist echt. Na klar, denn Fax wird als rechtlich verbindlich
gesehen. Ähnlich wie das Post. Ich denke, dass das auch so ist. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es
rechtlich wirklich so ist, aber da wird schon was dran sein. Ja, also ich habe auch schon so mal ein
paar Widersprüche und Sachen tatsächlich per Fax geschickt, dass ich mir sicher sein konnte,
die reden sich nicht mit raus, sie haben es nicht bekommen. Für eine E-Mail gilt das nicht unbedingt.
Schauen wir uns nachher nochmal genauer an. Und dann gibt es natürlich noch die öffentliche
Verwaltung. Digitalisierung in der Verwaltung. Tutorial Nummer 001. Wenn jemand digital
kommunizieren will, scannt das Formular ein, dann per E-Mail schicken. Es ist oftmals aber auch schon
deutlich besser geworden. Ich muss jetzt mal, hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass ich das mache. Aber ich
habe letztens meinen Personalausweis verlängern, äh, nee, nicht verlängern, ist das das falsche Wort, äh, beantragen
müssen. Der ist abgelaufen, ja. Du musst den alten ja dann abgelenken. Verlängern ist es ja nicht wirklich.
Zumal der bei mir schon in der, also warum habe ich das gemacht? Ganz einfach, weil ich am 1.4.
einen gültigen Personalausweis gebraucht habe, als ich beim neuen Arbeitgeber angefangen habe.
Ähm, davor, mein Ausweis ist seit, keine Ahnung, war fünf Jahre abgelaufen oder so. Richtig,
richtig outdated, lag ewig in der Schublade. Also wenn mich mal jemand kontrolliert hätte und ich
hätte dann gesagt, oh den habe ich vergessen und ich hätte ihn vorlegen müssen, hätte ich halt echt
Pech gehabt. Na gut. Zumindest habe ich den jetzt verlängern müssen oder halt neu beantragen oder
beantragen müssen und das ging wirklich gut. Stellt euch das mal vor, kein Fax, kein großes
Bürokratiekram. Man konnte sich, jetzt haltet euch fest, also es ist nicht alles schlecht und ich bin
mir auch relativ sicher, dass, okay, nee, das erzähle ich danach. Also erstmal wie das, wie das
ganze gelaufen ist. Ich bin online, ich kann euch das mal zeigen, Hanau Personalausweis, Reisepässe
und, ja, das zu finden war tatsächlich schon ein bisschen eklig. Wahrscheinlich finde ich es jetzt
gar nicht mehr. Hier, man konnte tatsächlich, konnte man online in einem Formular auswählen,
was man machen möchte. Dann kann man dann hier beispielsweise sagen, ich will Ausweis, ich will
Personalausweis. Ja, warum das so ein komisches Warenkorbding ist, keine Ahnung. Ja, ja, okay,
alles klar. So und dann kannst du hier anzeigen, okay, wo das, wo das ist, wo da, wo das, nein,
mein Standort wollen wir nicht abrufen. Und ihr aktueller Standort kann abweichen, ja,
der weicht doch ab. Okay, zumindest sieht man das hier, dass man das relativ, relativ gut drüber
machen kann. Standort liegt, fuck, ich wohne, warte mal, wohne ich hier oder wohne ich angeblich hier?
Hier in Main wohne ich, nice. Ja, das ist korrekt, ich kann es bestätigen, Leute. Meine private Insel
liegt genau exakt hier. Direkt, direkt mitten im Main. So und das kann man hier online tatsächlich
beantragen und ihr werdet es nicht glauben, das ging jetzt folgendermaßen. Ich habe mich online
zu einem Termin angemeldet, dann kriegst du so eine Nummer. Du musst nichts machen. Du gehst,
du nimmst dir einfach deine Nummer mit, gehst zu dem Datum hin und zu der Zeit, die dir eingetragen
wurde, wartest zwei, drei Minuten, dann erscheint deine Nummer auf dem Bildschirm und du kommst rein
zu einer Bearbeiterin in das Großraumbüro. Das ist wirklich gut gemacht. Und dann bist du da eine
Viertelstunde drin, musst noch ein Foto machen, musst noch irgendwie hier und da ein Geschütz
machen, was halt, was halt erforderlich ist dafür. Dann beantragen die das alles und dann kannst du
das abholen in drei, vier Wochen. Und da musst du auch nicht rein. Du gehst dann einfach vorne an
den, an diese Theke, sagst hier, ich will meinen Ausweis abholen. Hier ist das Dokument. Kriegst
deinen Ausweis und fertig. Das ist wirklich gut gemacht. Also ich gehe auch persönlich davon aus,
dass das nicht rein auf dem Mist der Verwaltung in Hanau gewachsen ist, sondern da irgendein
Drittanbieter daran beteiligt war, das so zu gestalten. Irgendeiner, der weiß, wie man das
macht. Ich glaube nicht, dass die Verwaltung in Hanau das alleine auf die Reihe gekriegt hat,
sowohl IT-technisch als auch Workflow-Ablauf mäßig. Das war wirklich gut. Kann ich nicht,
kann ich nicht meckern. Also das letzte Mal, als ich meinen Ausweis beantragen musste,
musste ich noch nach Hanau ins Rathaus, so ganz merkwürdig. Und dann hast du da auf dem Gang
gehockt und es war richtig eklig. Also mittlerweile wirklich gut. Also man sieht,
das kann funktionieren, was Verwaltung und Digitalisierung angeht. Das muss aber auch von
den entsprechenden Leuten gemacht werden, die wissen, wie sie das umsetzen. Du kannst dann
nicht den 0815-Typ für das Management des Projekts, nicht den 0815-Typ aus der Verwaltung
selbst nehmen, weil die haben einfach nicht den Plan dafür. Und auch nicht die richtigen Anreize
für oftmals. Aber in Hanau haben sie es wirklich gut gemacht. So, weiter.
Ausfüllen lassen, per E-Mail zurück annehmen, ausdrucken und dann...
Das war nicht so. Damit habe ich gerechnet. Damit habe ich gerechnet. War aber nicht so.
Woher kommt dieser Fetisch denn? Ist es der Geruch von Tintin? Hey, I don't judge you.
Jedem sein Fetisch. Ihr verurteilt mich auch nicht, weil ich euch von dem Typ erzähle.
Mir hat ein...
Also ich musste den auch automatisch... Nee, ich musste den auch abholen gehen,
persönlich den Ausweis. Aber ich konnte mir online einen Termin machen und dann halt passend
dazu hingehen.
...gezwitschert, dass Fax aber als sicherer gilt als E-Mail. Sicherer im Sinne gegen Hacker
und zuverlässiger als E-Mail, da Fax auch ohne Internet funktionieren soll.
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten. Ich meine, in Zeiten, wo die Leute einen reinen
VoIP-Anschluss haben, wenn das Internet weg ist, ist das Internet halt weg. Ob ich jetzt über den
VoIP oder reinen VoIP-IP-Anschluss da Fax schicke oder... Das macht wahrscheinlich keinen
großen Unterschied.
Sicherer gegen Hacker, ob... Naja... Keine Ahnung. Dadurch, dass auf dem Rechner nichts
gespeichert wurde, kann es halt im Nachhinein auch keiner mehr... Aber naja, da kann man sich
jetzt drüber streiten. Zuverlässiger würde ich sagen, ist es mittlerweile nicht mehr,
weil es nur noch VoIP-Anschlüsse gibt.
In der Cybersicherheit spricht man für gewöhnlich von drei Schutzzielen, der CIA-Triade. Das C steht
für Confidentiality, also Vertraulichkeit, das I für Integrität und das A für Availability,
also Verfügbarkeit. Wir starten mal nicht mit dem C, sondern mit dem A, also die Ausfallsicherheit.
Man muss ja in diesem Land auch irgendwie mit schlechtem Internet oder keinem Internet
umgehen können. Und wenn die Tankstelle keine Kartenzahlung annehmen kann, weil das ganze
Internet in der gesamten Straße ausfällt, ist das unpraktisch. Und genau das ist mir
übrigens passiert. Behörden nutzen Fax deshalb sehr gerne, weil das natürlich nicht mit ausfällt.
Telefon läuft ja auch anders. Zumindest war das mal so.
Ja, genau. Wollte ich gerade sagen. Ist ja bei vielen nicht mehr so.
Für Telefon ein Ding namens VoIP, also Voice over IP, allmählich durchsetzt. Für Fax ist das
Äquivalent VoIP. Also ja, I shit you not.
Ernsthaft? VoIP? Das hättest du nicht mega kacke abgehört sollen. Warum? Warum nicht? Okay, Leute.
Warum nicht? VoIP. Fax over Voice over IP. VoIP.
Fax over IP. Technisch reden wir hier vom T38-Protokoll. Ursprünglich wurde Fax ja auf der
Telefonleitung aufgesetzt und wurde mit Tonsignalen interpretiert. Deswegen dieser ikonische Sound-Effekt.
Genau. Deswegen gibt es noch zusätzlich aktuell das E711-Pass-Through, was im Endeffekt heißt,
dass Fax nimmt die Telefonleitung, die dann auch über das Internet geht. Aber Ton wird halt als
Fax interpretiert. Fax war aber so wichtig, dass es mit T38, also Fax over IP, auch einen eigenen
Standard... Warte, warte, warte. T38-Internet-Aware-Fax-IAV-over-UDP. Warum haben wir alles in der Welt über UDP?
Die Welt der Standards, man. Der wichtige Aspekt ist aber, Fax over IP nutzt eben genauso wie Voice
over IP das Internet. Ohne Internet kein Fax. Oder man muss natürlich noch ältere Technologien als
den neuesten Fax-Standard nutzen. Gleichzeitig wird Fax aber eingangs, wie wir gehört haben,
auch wegen seiner Sicherheit genutzt. In diesem Fall heißt das normalerweise,
niemand soll bitte mitlesen können. Also Confidentiality. Das, was wir übertragen,
soll gesichert sein. Anwaltsschreiben oder medizinische Befunde gehören zu den teuersten
Datensätzen im Darknet. Wäre ja ziemlich uncool, wenn ein Hacker die klauen würde, nicht wahr? In
der Cybersecurity gehen wir von einem Angreifermodell aus. Also ich muss ehrlich
sagen, diese Sache mit Fax. Ja, du kannst natürlich sagen, dass es prinzipiell bei Fax,
also wenn wir mal von der klassischen Telefonleitung ausgehen, da muss irgendjemand an die Leitung
drankommen, um das mithören zu können, dein Fax. Aber auf der anderen Seite, ganz ehrlich,
es gibt mittlerweile so gute und vor allem einfach zu benutzende Sicherheitsstandards.
Jeder kann sich ein Server mit einem Let's-Sign-Grip-Zertifikat aufsetzen. Und ich meine,
es muss ja nicht mal ein gültiges Zertifikat sein, dass du ordentlich HTTPS machen kannst oder TLS.
Also im Prinzip ist die Übertragung übers Internet mit aktueller Technik, so dass deine Daten gesichert
übertragen werden, nennen wir es mal ein gelöstes Problem. Das heißt, ich würde sogar sagen,
die Übertragung übers Internet, wenn das Ganze verschlüsselt läuft, ist wahrscheinlich
mindestens gleichwertig zu analogem Fax, wenn nicht sogar besser, weil es bringt noch nicht
mal was, wenn du an die Leitung drankommst. Du kannst damit schlicht und ergreifend nichts anfangen.
Wir sprechen bei Angriffsszenarien meist von einem Angreifer, der die gesamte Kommunikation
mitlesen kann. Also als hätte er Zugriff auf das Kabel. Und zwar immer. Das ist zwar nicht einfach
und nicht wirklich realistisch, aber wir nehmen einfach mal an, Vodafone würde gehackt werden.
Dann könnten die meinen gesamten Internetverkehr mitlesen. Alternativ könnten auch einfach mal ein
paar Behörden die Lauscherchen bei Vodafone installieren und dann mitlesen. Das ist ein
wirklich mächtiger Angreifer, von dem wir hier ausgehen. Also normalerweise sind die nicht so
stark, aber wir müssen einfach davon ausgehen. Um hier also medizinische Daten sinnvoll zu sichern
gegen so einen Angreifer, müssten wir sie eigentlich verschlüsseln. Und hier spricht man ganz gerne von
Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung, denn es bringt uns ja nichts, wenn zwischendrin jemand entschlüsselt.
Das gilt als der de facto Standard für Confidentiality. Wenn einem das nicht reicht,
kann man das Ganze natürlich auch noch verschlüsseln. Also zusätzlich, rein zu TLS bei
der Übertragung, kann man natürlich den Inhalt auch noch mal vorher verschlüsseln, bevor man es
überhaupt überträgt. Mit irgendeinem Key, den bloß du kennst oder die andere Seite kennst oder mit
irgendwelchen Public-Key-Trust-Geschichten. Kann man natürlich auch machen. Und da wird es halt
schwierig mit analogem Fax. Ich meine, du kannst theoretisch sicherlich ein analoges Fax auch
verschlüsseln, übertragen. Da müssen das aber beide Seiten unterstützen. Dann wird das halt
zuerst eingescannt und dann verschlüsselt und dann über Töne übertragen und dann wieder zurück.
Und wenn dann was verloren geht, lässt es sich nicht richtig entschlüsseln. Das stelle ich mir
eklig vor. Welche genau da verwendet werden, das erspare ich euch an der Stelle. Ich würde euch
allerdings niemals einen Messenger empfehlen, der keine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung hat. Sogar,
wenn ihr einfach nur am normal kommunizieren seid. Ja, könnte man sagen, warum benutzt man
noch Discord? Ganz einfach, weil es einfach angenehm ist. Aber das stimmt schon. Wirklich
vertrauenswürdige oder vertrauens... ja, vertrauens... wichtige Sachen sollte man
vielleicht nicht im Plaintext über Discord übertragen. Aber wie sieht es da mit hochsensiblen
Gesundheitsdaten aus? Das T38-Protokoll, also das fortschrittlichste Fax-Protokoll, das Fax
übers Internet schickt, hat an sich keine eingebaute Verschlüsselung. Das Protokoll
ist erstmal nur zum Versenden von Fax over IP. Man könnte jetzt noch ein bisschen TLS-Magie
einbauen, aber ich habe keine einzige Anwendung gefunden, die das explizit hervorhebt, dass sie
das tun. Und normalerweise würden die mit sowas definitiv Marketing machen. Und eigentlich ist
VoIP auch überhaupt nicht dafür vorgesehen. VoIP? Alter, ich komme nicht klar auf die Abkürzung.
Diese Infrastruktur aufzubauen, ist sehr komplex und aufwendig und eigentlich muss
jeder mitmachen. Kurzum, Faxe sind von Haus aus nicht verschlüsselt. Okay, aber dann doch
wenigstens die rechtliche Bindung, oder? Die Integrität. In Deutschland gibt es bestimmte
rechtliche Anforderungen, die die Form von Kommunikation in bestimmten Situationen
vorschreiben. In vielen Fällen ist eine schriftliche Form erforderlich, habt ihr
vielleicht schon mal gehört. Die wird in der Regel durch einen Brief erfüllt, weil der eben
eigenhändig unterschrieben ist. Weil der kann ja nicht abgefangen werden. Oder so. Ein Fax kann in
einigen Fällen als schriftliche Form anerkannt werden, da es eine echte Unterschrift übertragen
kann. Eine E-Mail wird insgesamt allerdings nicht in allen rechtlichen Kontexten als gleichwertig
anerkannt. Das muss dann als elektronische Form anerkannt sein. Das ist ja was anderes wie die
schriftliche Form. Der Hintergrund ist genau diese eigenhändige Unterschrift. Fun Fact zu
diesen eigenhändigen Unterschriften, diese Unterschriften sind offensichtlich leicht
fälschbar. Ja, natürlich. Habe ich ein einziges unterschriebenes Dokument von einer Person, kann
ich alles in ihrem Namen unterschreiben. Es gibt ja schon mittlerweile jede Menge digitale Signing
Services von Adobe oder sowas, wo man auch entweder seine Unterschrift im Vorfeld einscannt oder mit
der Maus unterschreibt oder irgendwie sowas hier. Das ist auch gültig. Ich habe eigentlich
keinen Vertrag mehr, was über irgendwelche Sponsoring Sachen oder Placements und sowas
ging, die letzten Jahre über wirklich noch physisch unterschrieben. Es war alles rein
digital und da verlassen sich auch beide Seiten drauf, dass sich alle dran halten.
Wegfaxen. Digitale Unterschriften hingegen funktionieren etwas anders. Sie unterschreiben
basierend auf den Bits und Bytes, die das zu unterschreibende Dokument enthält. Und nur der
Besitzer des Schlüssels kann diese Unterschrift erzeugen. Es dauert einige Milliarden Jahre,
sie zu fälschen. Aber gut, in Deutschland zählt die eigentlich nicht die digitale
Unterschrift. Zurück zum Fax also. Wie gesagt, T38, das Faxprotokoll, ist nicht verschlüsselt.
Die Unterschrift auf dem Fax ist also eine eigenhändige Unterschrift, kein digitale,
also ein Bild, das sich eben nur auf diesem Dokument befindet. Einen Angreifer, wie wir
ihn vorhin schon hatten, hindert also eigentlich nichts daran, das Dokument komplett zu ändern
und aus meiner Rechnung an Cedric Mössners IBAN Eve Angreifers IBAN zu machen. Die Unterschrift
bleibt dieselbe. Ich fasse nochmal kurz zusammen. Fax funktioniert nicht, wenn das Internet ausfällt.
Fax ist nicht verschlüsselt und auch nicht... Naja, also den Inhalt auszutauschen live
während der Faxübertragung stelle ich mir zwar möglich vor, aber doch ziemlich schwierig. Du
müsstest dann quasi die Leitung unterbrechen, bei dir einen Fax hinstellen, das empfangen,
das ändern und dann an den eigentlichen Empfänger weiterleiten. Ja, so kann man mal. Auf jeden Fall
nicht so easy. Aber ich verstehe gar nicht. Eigentlich ist es doof, dass man sich überhaupt
darum noch Gedanken machen muss. In diesem zugegebenermaßen technischen Szenario,
das unser theoretischer Angreifer beherrscht, kann der Angreifer alles lesen, alle Faxe abfangen und
alle Informationen austauschen. Dennoch vertrauen wir Fax unsere sensibelsten Daten an. Und übrigens
sind genau die angeführten Gründe auch der Grund, warum E-Mail nicht als offizielles Medium
anerkannt wird. Ja, ganz ehrlich ist es egal, ob es faktisch so ist oder nicht. Wenn du willst,
dass es, also wenn das noch so ist. Also selbst wenn das Schwachsinn ist aus technischer Sicht,
ja. Aber du wirst ja teilweise gezwungen dadurch, das so zu machen, wenn du sicher gehen willst,
dass es auch rechtzeitig angekommen ist und sowas. Scheiß drauf, ob du es bescheuert findest. Wenn
du sicher sein willst, hier Sendebeleg, guck mal da, halt Fax. Gut, allmählich schleicht sich E-Mail
da so ein bisschen rein. Und nein, ich finde E-Mail auch keine sinnvolle Alternative. Dazu aber
nachher mehr. Dazu kommt, die Faxgeräte... Na gut, E-Mail hat ein Problem. E-Mail ist nicht
als synchrone Kommunikation in dem Sinn gedacht. Also du kannst bei E-Mail nie wissen, dass die
E-Mail, die du abschickst auch wirklich angekommen ist oder beziehungsweise ankommen wird. Ja,
bei Fax weißt du das, weil du ja direkt mit der Gegenstelle sprichst. Und das ist tatsächlich
bei E-Mail so ein bisschen ein Problem. E-Mail kannst du so prinzipbedingt immer sagen,
habe ich nicht bekommen. Und dann ist es nicht einfach, das nachzuweisen, dass es wirklich
angekommen ist. Kannst du ja ohne Mitarbeiter, dazwischen stehenden E-Mail-Provider gar nicht.
Kosten auch Geld. Sie kosten Papier, sie kosten Material und natürlich Wartung. Und auf einem
Blatt Papier kann niemand eine Suche ausführen. Das bedeutet aber auch eben, dass ein Mensch das
Fax dann oft wieder händisch in eine Datenbank eintragen muss. Das ist verschwendete Lebenszeit.
Abseits davon wird oft noch die Sicherheit von Fax gegen Social Engineering angebracht. In einem
Fax kann kein Link drin sein, der zu einer bösartigen Webseite führt. Logisch. Na gut,
da ist was dran. Man kann ja nicht in Faxanhängen mitschicken, weil es kommt halt ein Blatt Papier
raus und da gibt es keine Anhänge. Dazu sage ich folgendes. Auch in der Freizeit können Geräte
von Mitarbeitern mit Malware infiziert werden. Dann kommen sie nichts an ins Unternehmen und
infizieren das ganze Unternehmen. Dann lieber Mitarbeiter aufklären und bilden. Und dann
klicken sie auch auf keine Phishing-Links in Mails mehr. Ja, mal ganz davon abgesehen,
die verwenden ja trotzdem E-Mail. Also insofern gebe ich ihm recht. Nur weil die ab und zu mal
einen Fax empfangen, wo dann halt kein Link drin sein kann, den man direkt anklicken kann,
benutzen die ja trotzdem E-Mail. Das ist ja nicht so, als machen die ihre komplette
Kommunikation nur über Fax. Die kriegen halt auch mal einen Fax. Ja, aber bringt ja nichts.
Der restliche Kram ist nach wie vor E-Mail, Sachen im Browser und so, wo das weiterhin geht.
E-Mails-Anhänge verbieten. Problem gelöst. Viel lustiger ist aber, es gibt durchaus Phishing
mit Fax. Der Fax-Rückruf-Scam. In diesem Fall erhält das Ziel, ein Fax, das behauptet,
von einer seriösen Organisation zu stammen und fordert das Ziel auf, eine bestimmte Nummer...
Fax-Scam. Alter, wir haben das Jahr 2023. Es gibt ernsthaft noch Scams über Fax? Das geht
auch nur noch in Deutschland, oder? ...zurückzurufen. Die Nummer ist jedoch
eine kostenpflichtige Nummer und das Ziel wird mit hohen Gebühren belastet. Oder Fax-Phishing.
Hierbei erhält das Ziel, ein Fax, das behauptet, von einer Bank oder einer anderen Finanzinstitution
zu stammen und das Fax fordert dann das Ziel auf, persönliche oder finanzielle Informationen
preiszugeben, die dann von den Angreifern verwendet werden. Und die auch einfach per
Fax zurückgeschickt werden können. Das kann natürlich auch eine andere Institution sein,
wie zum Beispiel eine Gesundheitsinstitution, ein Arzt, der sich als jemand anders ausgibt
und so weiter und so fort. Also nein, nein und nein. So, genug gelacht. Jetzt nochmal ganz kurz
zurück auf Ernst. Ich hatte eingangs erwähnt, dass Ärzte tatsächlich Papierbefunde schreiben
und die dann rumfaxen. Diese Befunde sind demnach handgeschrieben. Die ärztliche Handschrift ist aber
leider in echt vielen Fällen unlesbar. Das stimmt. Nein, es ist kein Klischee und nein,
ich mache den Ärzten auch keinen Vorwurf. Diese armen Menschen stehen teilweise 24 Stunden im OP,
um Leben zu retten. Ich könnte danach auch nicht mehr schreiben. Allerdings führt dieser
handschriftliche Befund dazu, dass es andere Menschen oft nicht lesen können. Und wenn dann
der Arzt mal kurz am Schlafen ist, dann treten vielleicht Fragen auf, weil es nicht gelesen
werden kann. Und dann kann sowas tatsächlich Menschenleben kosten. Redet gerne mal mit
Menschen im Gesundheitswesen. Das ist tatsächlich ein Thing. Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. Eine KI
kann diese Schrift nicht lesen. Ein Diktiergerät zum Beispiel könnte hier wirklich Leben retten.
Verbot von Fax. So, call me linksgrünversiffter Verbotsjünger, aber ich kann diese veralteten
Technologien nicht mehr. Fax muss weg. Und das Wichtigste dabei ist, die Leute dürfen nicht
alleingelassen werden. Ja, das Ding ist halt. Solange es halt noch Vorteile in manchen Bereichen
hat, kannst du es nicht einfach verbieten. Wie gesagt, wenn ich finde es ja auch bescheuert,
dass ich nicht einfach eine E-Mail schicken kann oder ein Formular hochladen kann bei denen auf
der Webseite, was auch immer, sondern wenn ich wirklich sicher beweisen können muss, das Ganze
war vor 12 Uhr Freitag dort, dass ich da einen Fax schicken muss mit so einem hässlichen Sende
Beleg oder einen Brief. Sollte das nicht mehr der Fall sein und es da verbindliche andere
Möglichkeiten geben, bin ich sofort dabei zu sagen Scheiß auf Fax. Krankenhaus hat noch die Zeit,
sich um die Umstellung zu kümmern. Fürs Gesundheitswesen werden gerade die spannendsten
KI-Technologien entwickelt, die ich je gesehen habe. Google hat gerade ihre Pan-Med-Software
angefangen in den USA zu testen. Also lass mal die einfachen Bereiche angucken. Behörden. In
der Gematik hat es angefangen. Dort wird nun Matrix im Einsatz getestet und dafür möchte ich
mal ausdrücklich Lob aussprechen. Wie gesagt, E-Mail ist nicht besser als Fax. Von Haus aus
unverschlüsselt und häufig liegen die Daten bei Google und Co. Matrix ist da anders. Matrix ist
ein verschlüsseltes Protokoll. Ihr könnt es euch ein bisschen wie WhatsApp oder Signal vorstellen,
nur eben der Hintergrund davon. Man kann Einzelpersonen schreiben, aber halt auch Gruppen.
XMPP, beste Leute. Jabber, falls das noch jemand von euch kennt. Jabber war richtig pock
zeitlang. Hat sich nie so richtig durchgesetzt. Kennt ihr noch Jabber? Nicht-Disco-Jabber. Einfach
nur Jabber. XMPP. IMC, ja. Ohne Scheiß, Leute. Also vieles von dem, also wir reden jetzt mal rein
von Text-Messages, ja. Vieles von dem, was die Leute heute sagen, oh, unterschiedliche Themenräume,
unterschiedliche und das und Messages und alles, was die Leute heute beispielsweise in Discord
feiern, das gab's 1990 mit IRC schon. Es war halt rein textbasiert und ja, es gab so ein paar
Erweiterungen über IRC zum Dateischeren und so. Das war allerdings nie sonderlich geil rein für
Text. IRC war nicht übel. Stellt es euch auch ein bisschen wie einen Discord-Server vor,
Twitch-Chat. Was basiert, bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob es, ich glaube es basiert noch,
aber die haben doch irgendwie immer mehr Features abgeschaltet, was, was IRC angeht.
Können miteinander interagieren können. Aber der große Unterschied, jeder kann eben seinen eigenen
Server betreiben. Die Gematik hat einen eigenen. Die Behörde Berlin kann dann einen eigenen haben
und so weiter. IRC ist unverschlüsselt. Ja, aber du konntest das, ich weiß nicht,
was es für Möglichkeiten gibt, IRC zu verschlüsseln. Gab's bestimmt auch was.
Variiert dezentral. Und jeder User hat seinen ganz eigenen Namen, der immer bleibt. Morpheus
at bootstrap.academy zum Beispiel. Keine Sorge, den gibt's nicht wirklich. Das ist wie eine
E-Mail-Adresse im Endeffekt, nur, dass eben Matrix komplett verschlüsselt ist. Ich kann
Dateien schicken, natürlich auch Formulare. Im Endeffekt wie bei einem Messenger. Es hat
auch mehrere Messenger-Frontends, also Apps, die ihr installieren könnt und die im Hintergrund
dann Matrix benutzen. Und man könnte sogar einen Bot laufen lassen als deutscher Staat,
der die einzelnen Formulare automatisiert mit einem Frage-Antwort-Spiel. Jetzt ist er aber
ein bisschen zu advanced für unsere Verwaltungs-ID. Aber das ist natürlich Zukunftsmusik. Das sind
alles nur Möglichkeiten oder Alternativen. Denn es gibt sie. Man müsste sie eben nur
genau so anpassen, dass sie auch funktionieren. Aber fax, das kann's einfach nicht mehr sein.
Faxge. In 40 Jahren vielleicht. In unserer Geschwindigkeit dauert das bestimmt noch so
lange. Nee, das weißt du bei einer E-Mail nicht. Bei einer E-Mail siehst du nur, wenn ich eine
E-Mail verschicke, sehe ich als Absender nur, selbst wenn ich mir die Protokolle angucke,
dass ich das an meinen E-Mail-Provider per SMTP zugestellt habe. Mehr sehe ich nicht.
Ob das Ding dann ankommt oder nicht, das weiß ich nicht. Der Empfänger kann noch ein bisschen
mehr sehen vielleicht bei allen möglichen Headern in der E-Mail. Aber ansonsten,
also du hast als Sender einer E-Mail keine Möglichkeit zu kontrollieren oder sicherzustellen,
dass die innerhalb oder bis zu Zeit X auch wirklich eingegangen ist. Wie willst du mehr
sehen? Wie willst du mehr sehen? Das Versenden deiner E-Mail ist fertig, sobald du es per SMTP
abgegeben hast bei deinem E-Mail-Provider. Das siehst du doch nicht als E-Mail-Sender.
Also ich meine, ich will jetzt nicht ausschließen, dass es da mittlerweile was gibt,
aber normalerweise siehst du das nicht. Es kann ja auch durchaus sein, dass das mal ein bisschen
dauert. Ja, mach Screenshot. Pog. Pass auf, jetzt gibt's einen Link zu einem Screenshot,
wo wir gerickrolled werden. Vielleicht, ja, vielleicht. Deswegen, du kannst dich nicht
darauf verlassen, dass deine E-Mail bis zum Zeitpunkt X... Mal angenommen, du hast Zeitpunkt
zum Einreichen deiner Abschlussprüfung bis Freitag 12 Uhr. Das ist aber übertrieben gesagt, ja? So,
und das musst du ja im Zweifelsfall auch beweisen können, dass du das eingereicht hast rechtzeitig.
Das ist egal, wenn das vom Fax in den Schredder reingeht, dann ist es angekommen. Zumindest kannst
du dann den Sendebeleg zeigen. Ob die das schreddern auf der Seite, ist egal. Also das ist
halt das Dumme, dir bleibt dann nur so Sachen übrig, wie du musst das per Einschreiben hinschicken
oder per Fax. Du kannst ja nicht mal wissen, ob die E-Mail richtig beim Empfängerserver eingegangen
ist. So, was gucken wir uns denn jetzt als nächstes an? Du brauchst nie wieder Passwörter,
so einfach sind Passkeys. Dann gucken wir uns das doch jetzt mal an. Guck mal hier,
das bin ich, wie ich mir ein sicheres Passwort ausdenke. Die Lautstärke, okay. Guck mal hier,
das bin ich, wie ich mir ein sicheres Passwort ausdenke. Ich denke mir ein sicheres Passwort
ganz einfach aus, indem ich meinen Passwortmanager auf Passwort generieren klicke und das dann
verwende. Und manchmal, wisst ihr, was mich immer so richtig abfuckt, was bei Web-Services? Ich gehe
in meinen Passwortmanager, drücke auf Passwort generieren und der wirft mir dann, keine Ahnung,
36-stelliges Passwort aus mit Groß-Kleinschreiben, Groß-Kleinschreibung und Zahlen. Okay. Dann hast
du manche Seiten, da kopierst du das rein, da kommt dann, das Passwort darf nicht länger als 18
Stellen sein. Oder du hast ein 36-stelliges Passwort und es kommt, das Passwort muss aber
mindestens ein Sonderzeichen enthalten. Ich meine, 36 Stellen, Mann, scheiß auf Sonderzeichen. Das
ist vollkommen okay, auch ohne Sonderzeichen. Lass mich in Ruhe. Oder darf dieses Sonderzeichen
nicht enthalten? Ja, das gibt es auch noch. Verständlich. Ja, das ist, das ist gut. Das
haben wir auch schon mal gemacht. Gut, es gibt natürlich auch Tools, die das für euch machen
und dann noch abspeichern. Also OnePassword, BitWarden, den Schlüsselbund von euren Handy-Anbietern.
Aber es gibt noch was viel besseres. Okay. Im Unterschied zu herkömmlichen Passwörtern sind
Passkeys deutlich komfortabler und auch sicherer. Oder direkt LastPass, genau. Während normale
Passwörter vereinfacht werden. Modgis, tut mir mal einen Gefall und achtet mal drauf, ob, weil ich
habe es jetzt noch nicht gesehen, den Link zu diesem E-Mail-Protokoll, was jemand schicken wollte,
das interessiert mich echt, ob man das nachvollziehen kann. Ich bin immer noch der Meinung, das geht nicht.
Auf den Servern liegen gibt es beim Passkey zwei Kryptoschlüssel. Einen, den nur du hast und
einen, den auch der Anbieter hat. Damit bist du nicht nur gegen Phishing geschützt, sondern auch
generell sicherer unterwegs. Auch wenn der Server gehackt wird, kann niemand Passwörter rekonstruieren.
Es ist quasi doppelt verschlüsselt. Einmal vom Cloud-Anbieter und einmal von dir. Das heißt,
wenn ich mein Gerät verliere, passiert nichts. Und wenn der Cloud-Anbieter geleakt Daten hat,
dann bringt es auch nichts. Eine Erfindung, die vielleicht mal ein paar Jahre kommt,
das geht schon heute. Bei Google, Microsoft oder Adobe zum Beispiel. Und in den nächsten Monaten
wird sich da viel tun. Passkeys sind also im Prinzip virtuelle Schlüssel, die auf deinem
Smartphone, deinem Computer oder einem speziellen USB-Stick gespeichert werden. Und dann musst du
nur noch deinen Fingerabdruck oder Face-ID verwenden und schon bist du eingeloggt. Und
das Beste, du musst dir nie wieder ein Passwort merken oder auf Phishing-Webseiten reinfallen.
Wie das genau funktioniert und wie du das direkt einsetzen kannst, bleibt dran.
Ja Moment, das ist das Log von deinem Postfix. Ja Moment, das Log von deinem Postfix,
das siehst du doch nicht in deinem E-Mail-Client. Beziehungsweise das Log von dem gegenüberliegenden
Provider-Server siehst du doch selbst nicht. Das siehst du nicht. Woher willst du das wissen? Also,
was du hier, also okay, das ist ein lokaler Postfix bei dir. Was du hier siehst ist,
dass dein lokaler, dass dieser Server eine E-Mail bekommen hat zu dieser Zieladresse und ja, die
wahrscheinlich weitergeleitet hat zu Gmx. Okay, ja, aber das siehst, also erstens, wenn es bei
dir lokal ist, dann weißt du ja nicht, was das Ding dahinter macht, ob das wirklich angekommen
ist. Es könnte ja auch sein, dass du eine E-Mail schickst zu, keine Ahnung, theonline.de oder so
und dann weiß ich nicht, ob dein lokaler Postfix es nur weiter schickt zu Gmx oder ob du tatsächlich
von dir was zu theonline schicken könntest und selbst wenn, selbst wenn, dieses Log hast du doch
als Anbieter nicht. Hast du doch als, nee, nicht als Anbieter. Das Log hat doch nur der Betreiber
des E-Mail-Servers. Das hast du doch nicht als, als E-Mail-Verschicker. Wenn ich jetzt eine E-Mail
verschicke über meinen Thunderbird oder so, dann sehe ich genau, also wenn ich mir, selbst wenn
ich die Kommunikation mitschneiden, mitschneiden sollen, würde, dann hätte ich den Log, wo drin
steht, Hello SMTP, E-Mail an den Webs, an den Mail-Server übergeben per SMTP, aber das hier sehe
ich ja dann gar nicht. Das hier sieht nur der Betreiber des E-Mail-Servers. Ja, ja klar, ja wenn
das geht, dann brauchen, wenn das möglich wäre, so ohne weiteres das nachvollziehen zu können, dann
bräuchte kein Fax mehr, aber das ist ja zurzeit nicht möglich, das so ohne weiteres nachzuvollziehen.
Natürlich, wenn du deinen eigenen E-Mail-Server betreibst, der aus irgendwelchen Gründen trusted
wird von allen anderen E-Mail-Servern, was tatsächlich, weiß nicht, wie du das hingekriegt
hast, nee hast du auch nicht hingekriegt, ist gar nicht so einfach, deinen eigenen E-Mail-Server zu
betreiben, der wirklich per SMTP Sachen bekommt und dann weiterleiten kann an andere, weil die
vertrauen normalerweise einem ganz ausgewählten Benutzerkreis, zwecks, zwecks Spam, dann bist du
ja quasi zwei Sachen in einer Person, du bist der Provider, du bist der Anbieter des E-Mail-Servers
und du bist der Client, der deine E-Mail verschickt, dass du als Anbieter des E-Mail-Servers nachvollziehen
kannst, was da passiert, ist ja das eine, aber du kannst als Benutzer deine E-Mail verschicktes
trotzdem nicht nachvollziehen. Okay, weiter geht's.
Liebe Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von NordVPN.
Man kann ja mit VPNs viele tolle Sachen machen, aber wusstet ihr, dass man...
Ende.
Also das Problem mit Passwörtern, die gibt es schon länger als das Internet und die sind deswegen auch nicht an die Realität des Internets und die Cyberkriminalität angepasst.
Das Prinzip, einen Benutzernamen und eine Reihenfolge von Zahlen, Buchstaben und Sonderzeichen zu verwenden, um sich zu identifizieren, ist nicht wirklich sicher.
Denn wenn jemand Zugang zu den Servern des Anbieters hat oder dein Passwort sonst irgendwie geleakt wird, dann können kriminelle Menschen viel Schindluder damit treiben.
Deswegen speichert dein Anbieter ja hoffentlich die Passwörter auch nicht im Klartext.
Aber es stimmt schon, du hast insofern gelitten, weil spätestens wenn du einen Keylogger oder sowas hast bei dir auf dem Rechner, dann kannst du schlicht und ergreifend die Passwörter halt mitlesen.
Oder diese Keypass-Lücke, die es letztens gab, wo du aus dem Speicher mehr oder weniger die komplette Keypass-Datenbank extrahieren konntest.
Dann hast du gelitten.
Und das ist das, wo bisher immer noch zum größten Teil Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung ins Spiel kommt.
Dass das alleine halt nicht reicht.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Sobald ein Anbieter euch die Möglichkeit gibt, euer Passwort zu restoren, beziehungsweise verschlüsselte Daten zu recovern, dann ist die Verschlüsselung für den Arsch.
Dann stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Passwort-Reset selbst, ich weiß, dass du weißt, wie es funktioniert, aber Passwort-Reset selbst ist ja kein Problem.
Da wird ja nicht das Passwort wiederhergestellt von dem, was du verwendet hast, sondern es wird ein neues Passwort vergeben.
Das ist kein Problem, solange es um den Zugang zu bestimmten Services geht, dann kann man das machen.
Solange es um das Entschlüsseln von Dateien beispielsweise geht, dann geht das mit Passwort-Reset logischerweise nicht.
Weil die Daten wurden ja schon mal verschlüsselt mit Key X und den kann ich nicht einfach resetten, weil ich habe ja den Plaintext nicht.
Also sobald ein Anbieter sagt, hey, wenn ihr euer Passwort vergessen habt, könnt ihr hier eure Daten recovern, dann sind die nie richtig verschlüsselt gewesen.
Also zumindest nicht so, wie ihr das gerne hättet.
Weil gute Verschlüsselung heißt im Endeffekt auch, Key verloren, Daten verloren.
Das muss so sein, alles andere wäre ja bescheuert, wenn du easy recovern könntest.
Es gibt ja meistens so ein paar Zwischenschritte und zwar ist es ja oft so, dass die Daten gar nicht direkt mit dem Passwort verschlüsselt werden,
sondern dass ein random Key erzeugt wird, mit dem werden die Daten verschlüsselt und der Key wird mit eurem Passwort verschlüsselt.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn ihr eure Festplatte verschlüsselt, wenn ihr Vollverschlüsselung von Daten auf der Festplatte macht
und ihr müsst beim Booten ein Passwort eingeben, damit quasi alles entschlüsselt wird,
dann wird nicht wirklich die Daten mit eurem Passwort entschlüsselt, sondern es liegt ein Key auf der Platte,
der wird entschlüsselt mit eurem Passwort und mit diesem Key werden dann die Daten entschlüsselt.
Warum macht man das? Es liegt ganz einfach daran, es liegt ganz einfach unter anderem an Performancegründen,
beispielsweise für Festplattenverschlüsselung ist es sinnvoll, wenn die Keys eine exakt vorher bekannte Länge haben,
die dann aligned ist an irgendwelchen Byte-Grenzen und sowas, das ist ein Performance-Ding.
Und Veracrypt bzw. Truecrypt macht das so, die speichern diesen Key einmal am Anfang von der Platte und einmal am Ende von der Platte,
weil nicht nur, wenn ihr euer Passwort vergessen habt, auch wenn der Key kaputt ist, habt ihr ein Problem.
Das sind zwei Sachen, die ihr da braucht. Ihr braucht einmal den Random Key,
der mit eurem Passwort verschlüsselt wird auf der Platte und euer Passwort, dass das funktioniert.
Deswegen speichert Veracrypt das einmal am Anfang der Disk und einmal am Ende der Disk.
Falls ihr aus Versehen die Platte überschreibt, habt ihr noch genug Zeit,
Steuerung C zu drücken und das Ende der Disk ist noch da und ihr könnt das Ganze noch auslesen.
Oder falls es irgendwie mal kaputt geht oder sowas.
Tatsächlich, es ist komplizierter, als es aussieht.
Deswegen gibt es schon länger die Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Die kennt man, wenn man Online-Banking macht, aber auch Google, Apple und andere große Anbieter zwingen der Benutzerschaft das im Prinzip mittlerweile auf.
Das sorgt dafür, dass du neben deinem Benutzernamen und dem Kennwort noch einen zweiten Faktor für die Anwendung benutzt.
Sekunde Leute, ich muss mal kurz, wo wir gerade beim Thema Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung sind.
Da kannst du davon ausgehen, dass sie das in irgendeiner Art und Weise geschützt haben gegen Brute Force und vorberechnete Hashes.
Die haben sogar noch ein bisschen mehr.
Du hast bei Veracrypt noch ein zusätzliches Setting, was auch noch als zweiter oder dritter Faktor fungiert.
Du kannst bei Veracrypt noch eingeben, wie oft versucht wird, das durch einen Verschlüsselungs- und Entschlüsselungs-Algorithmus zu jagen.
Also zum Beispiel, ihr habt ein Passwort oder ihr wollt irgendwas verschlüsseln.
Mit einem Passwort, mit einem Key, wollt ihr was verschlüsseln?
Die einfachste Variante ist, okay, ich hab ein Passwort, ich hab einen Plaintext und ich wende da jetzt meinen Verschlüsselungs-Algorithmus drauf an und am Ende fällt irgendwas Verschlüsselndes bei raus.
PIM ist, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, noch eine zusätzliche Zahl, wie oft das im Kreis verschlüsselt wird.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich sage, okay, ich hab ein Passwort und ich hab einen Plaintext, den ich verschlüsseln will, aber als PIM nehme ich beispielsweise noch 65.
Ich glaube, das ist PIM in dem Fall.
65, dann passiert Folgendes.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das wirklich so ist.
Ja, aber ich glaube, ich kriege es halbwegs aus dem Kopf zusammen.
Es wird einmal verschlüsselt mit eurem Passwort.
Dann wird der verschlüsselte Output genommen und wieder als Input reingefüttert.
Und das Ganze 65 Mal.
Das macht Brutforce-Angriffe natürlich deutlich rechenintensiver, wenn ihr das 65 Mal machen müsst.
Und ihr müsst erstmal wissen, was für ein PIM gewählt wurde.
Ja, Personal Iterations Multiplier.
Hier.
Controls the number of iterations used by header key.
Ja, ist doch im Prinzip das, was ich erzählt habe.
Genau.
Das heißt, du gibst dann nicht nur dein Passwort ein, du musst dann auch noch einen passenden PIM dazu eingeben.
Wie oft das quasi dann durchlaufen lassen wird, um dann auf den richtigen Key zu kommen.
Und dann zu gucken, ob es funktioniert.
Das heißt, es ist quasi nochmal so eine Art dritter Faktor, den man wissen muss.
Der PIM.
Ja.
Wie sind wir jetzt eigentlich da drauf gekommen?
Ja, dann macht es der Anbieter falsch.
Passwörter per Klartext verschicken können, weil es der Anbieter hat Kacke gebaut.
Bei Google wird das beispielsweise per Benachrichtigung über die Google Play-Dienste auf Smartphones gelöst.
Bei Apple bekommst du auf ein anderes Apple-Gerät mit deiner Apple-ID einen Code und musst auf Bestätigen klicken.
Und selbst die vermeintlich altmodische SMS ist auf jeden Fall schon sicherer.
Wobei, ganz ehrlich, wobei das immer noch ein Risiko bietet.
Ich muss ja das irgendwann mal einrichten.
So.
Und das ist eigentlich der Knackpunkt.
Was übrigens für mich eines der prinzipiellen Knackpunkte ist,
nicht Open-Source-Passwort-Managern bzw. Cloud-Anbietern.
Ich müsste nicht nur dem Verfahren vertrauen
und dem Anbieter, dass ich sage, okay, die werden schon wissen, was sie machen und nichts übertragen,
was nicht übertragen werden sollte und so.
Nein.
Ich muss auch mich darauf verlassen,
dass das in meinem Sinne implementiert ist.
Mal angenommen, ich benutze irgendeine App dafür, um das Initial einzurichten.
Ich habe doch keine Ahnung, was diese App wirklich macht.
Die App kann sagen, okay, wir machen das alles furchtbar sicher
und sonst werden wir in der Wirklichkeit alles in Plaintext übertragen.
Ich weiß das ja nicht. Ich kann das ja nicht nachvollziehen.
Das ist eines der größten Knackpunkte daran,
was auch der Grund ist, warum ich nur Open-Source-Passwort-Manager benutze.
Und welche, die seit einer Weile etabliert sind.
... als sich eben nur mit Namen und Passwort anzünden.
Ja, das stimmt.
Noch sicherer fährt man aber mit Passkeys.
Die Technik dahinter gibt es schon länger.
Das Authentifizierungsverfahren basiert auf FIDO2, WebAuthn
sowie CTAP2 und wurde von der FIDO...
Ach, CTAP2, sagst doch gleich, dann hätte ich sofort gewusst.
...Lions entwickelt.
Die gibt es seit 2012 und dazu gehören u.a. Apple, Google, Intel,
Microsoft, PayPal oder auch das BSI,
das Bundesamt für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik.
Also quasi alle wichtigen Player,
die irgendwie mit Cybersecurity in ihren Produkten zu tun haben
und deswegen auch ein Interesse daran haben,
dass die Menschen bestmöglich geschützt sind.
Das Problem allerdings an den bisherigen FIDO-Standards,
die daraus hervorgegangen sind,
die sind einfach zu komplex für die meisten Leute.
Da muss man sich extra Hardware für anstaffen.
Boston YubiKey z.B.
In den meisten Fällen ein extra Schlüssel für jedes Gerät erstellen.
Und wahrscheinlich wisst ihr es selbst am besten,
man hat ja schon genug damit zu tun,
den meisten Menschen im eigenen Umfeld zu erklären,
warum sie für jeden Dienst ein eigenes Passwort brauchen.
Und das am besten nicht,
Name meiner Tochter 123 sein sollte, ist klar.
Aber genau das könnte sich jetzt mit den Passkeys ändern.
Weil die auch in der Praxis, was den Komfort angeht,
ernsthaft mit simplen Passwörtern konkurrieren können.
Denn Passkeys weichen etwa
von den strengen Sicherheitsanforderungen
der Vorgänger ab.
Kryptoschlüsse können synchronisiert werden
oder am PC über das Smartphone
per QR-Code und Bluetooth verwendet werden.
Aber was macht jetzt ein Passkey so anders als ein Passwort?
Ja, erzähl mal.
Ich bin gespannt.
Wenn du einen Anbieter online einloggen möchtest
und du Passkey auswählst,
dann gibt der Webdienst deinem Gerät
eine zufällige Datenfolge, das heißt Challenge.
Dein Gerät signiert diese Challenge dann
mit dem privaten Key,
der eben nur auf deinem Gerät gespeichert ist.
Und dann kann der Webdienst über den öffentlichen Key überprüfen,
ob die Signatur wirklich
von deinem privaten Key stammt.
Okay.
Okay, ja.
Das leuchtet
so weit ein.
Aber jetzt ist es doch noch kein großartiges Problem,
wenn jemand
meinen privaten Key klaut, oder?
Wenn jemand meinen privaten Key klaut,
dann
also bis jetzt noch nicht
alles so rosig, ne?
Also wenn jetzt einer meinen privaten Key
klauen sollte,
weil einer Daten extra
hier hat von meinem Handy
und ich mich dann damit einlogge,
dann
noch ist das jetzt so nicht so.
Falls euch das Verfahren jetzt irgendwie bekannt vorkommt,
kann gut sein, denn das ist seit Jahrzehnten
etabliert. Heißt Public-Key-Kryptografie
und wird zum Beispiel bei HTTPS
oder Mailverschlüsselung oder Instant-Messaging
eingesetzt. Ja, aber trotzdem,
deswegen wohl heißt der private Key auch private Key.
Um dieses Verfahren jetzt eben auf eine
Massenbasis zu bringen, haben die führenden
Anbieter beschlossen, das in ihre Systeme
einzubauen und als Passkey
zu vermarkten. Und im Gegensatz zum Passwort
gibt es beim Passkey
eben kein shared secret, also
kein geteiltes Geheimnis, also eine Reihenfolge
von Zeichen, die sowohl der Anbieter
als auch die Benutzer kennen. Jasper, danke für den Sub.
Der private Key liegt nur bei dir und kann
deswegen auch nicht abgefangen werden.
Das ist also unter der Gruppe sicherer.
Ja gut, aber sag mal so,
gehen wir mal von dem Angriffsszenario
Keylogger, Rootkit, was auch immer aus,
mal angenommen jemand hat Zugriff auf mein Gerät,
auf dem ist ja auch der private Key gespeichert.
Zumindest wurde bis jetzt
noch nichts anderes erwähnt.
Adio und danke für den Sub.
Aber in der
Benutzung viel komfortabler.
Das sieht dann beim Einloggen so aus. Einfach
den Login eingeben und dann auf
mit Passkey anmelden klicken, Finger
auflegen oder Gesicht scannen und schon
bist du drin. Je nachdem wie der Anbieter
das Login-Verfahren aufbaut, musst du in
einigen Fällen sogar gar keinen Login-Namen
eingeben, sondern kannst den Passkey
direkt verwenden. Und Phishing ist mit
Passkeys auch kein Problem mehr, weil
ihr könnt den Passkey nur auf der Website benutzen,
für die ihr ihn erstellt habt.
Ah!
Ach so!
Das heißt ich hab
ja trotzdem, also mal angenommen
ich erstelle mir
einen Passkey, also im Prinzip
einen neuen privaten Schlüssel dann, bei mir auf dem
Gerät für Login auf Seite XY.
Okay, aber das kann doch trotzdem
jemand auslesen und sich damit einloggen
auf Seite XY, oder? Also ich mein
den großen Unterschied sehe ich
jetzt noch nicht.
Die funktioniert also nur auf
Passkeys.com und nicht auf Paypal,
Fakeaccount, sonst was, .org
oder so. Ihr seid deshalb automatisch
vor Phishing geschützt. Und ich hab's
ja gerade schon gesagt, Passkeys kann man
heute schon benutzen. Zum Beispiel hier bei
Google. Da könnt ihr nach diesem Video direkt in die
Account-Einstellung und dann hier auf Sicherheit
und dann auf Passkeys klicken und hier
Passkey erstellen. Und schon habt ihr
einen Passkey. Wenn ihr das erstmal so ausprobieren
wollt, könnt ihr auf Passkey.org
gehen. Dort gebt ihr einfach einen Login-Namen
ein und erstellt dann dafür
den Passkey. Dann geht ihr auf ein anderes Gerät,
in unserem Beispiel von einem MacBook auf dem
iPhone und gebt hier dann den Login-Namen
ein und könnt dann einfach sehen, dass
die Synchronisation des Passkeys geklappt hat.
Apple speichert die Passkeys nämlich im
verschlüsselten iCloud-Backup und
synchronisiert sie auf allen
Apple-Geräten, in die ihr eingeloggt seid.
Das heißt, wenn euer iPhone kaputt geht
und ihr ein neues kauft, sind darauf direkt alle
Passkeys gespeichert. Ja gut, jetzt
ist mein privater
Private Key in der Apple Cloud.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, Apple kann sich jetzt
was sie natürlich offiziell nicht
wissen, den Schlüssel, aber
gehen wir mal davon aus, jetzt kann sich theoretisch
Apple überall einloggen,
wo ich
Private Keys für generiert habe.
Ob sie es jetzt machen, ob sie es können,
sei mal dahingestellt. Ich habe keine Möglichkeit zu überprüfen,
ob sie das können
oder nicht. Wenn ihr mehrere Apple-Geräte
benutzt, dann sind auf allen Geräten
automatisch eure Passkeys hinterlegt.
Diese Synchronisation bietet auch Google an,
also zwischen mehreren Android-Geräten,
plattformübergreifend geht das aber
Stand heute noch nicht.
Wenn das jemand Cloud ist, ist die Seite hoffentlich
so gut, dass die merken, dass die Location anders ist.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn jemand
das Cloud,
die Location, an was wollen sie die Location
festmachen? Wenn jemand so schlau ist,
dann wird er sich auch über irgendeine deutsche
IP aus meinem Bereich
oder mit einem gleichen User-Agent
und was auch immer, das hinbekommen,
sich da einzuloggen.
Also das würde ich dann
den Leuten, die das schaffen, aus meinem Handy auszulesen,
auch noch zutrauen, dass sie
einen VPN aufbauen nach Deutschland.
Aber ganz ehrlich gesagt,
das docktert ja im Prinzip dann nur wieder Sachen
drumherum. Also ich
gätte das jetzt soweit, dass man quasi
etwas hat, was
sagen wir mal ähnliche Nachteile
hat, wie ein Passwort,
wenn es geleaked wird,
aber
schwerer zu leaken ist
und genauso einfach in der Handhabung.
So sehe ich
das jetzt aktuell. Bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich das alle so richtig kapiert habe.
Also es ist nach wie vor
ein Passwort, nur dadurch, dass es
besser integriert ist und du
es nicht im Plaintext mehr eintippen musst,
irgendwo
ein bisschen besser geschützt ist
und halt die Handhabung
deutlich einfacher ist, als
Passwörter einzutippen.
Passkeys
einzeln auf euren Windows-Rechnern,
Android-Smartphones oder iPad speichern,
aber eben nicht die gleichen Passkeys verwenden.
Einige Anbieter von Passwort-Managern
haben aber schon angekündigt, dass sie
zeitnah Versionen mit Passkey-Funktionen
anbieten werden und damit können die Passkeys
dann auch zwischen Windows, Linux, Android und
Apple-Geräten synchronisiert werden.
OnePassword hat Passkeys sogar schon in die Beta-Version
integriert und quasi alle anderen bekannten
Anbieter von Passwort-Managern... Naja gut, das Gute
an Passwörtern ist in dem Fall halt,
der einzige, der das Passwort...
Das heißt, das kann man jetzt drehen
und wenden, wie man will.
Wenn wir mal im besten Fall davon ausgehen,
du hast ein komplexes Passwort, was nur
in deinem Kopf gespeichert ist und sonst nirgendwo,
dann hat ja auch keiner Zugriff
drauf.
Private Key ist ja immer noch auf deinem Gerät
gespeichert, was man eventuell in irgendeiner Art und Weise
extrahieren kann. Aber ja, ich gebe zu,
das ist natürlich immer der Optimal-Fall.
Die meisten Leute haben es dann doch irgendwo
in Passwort.txt
auf dem Desktop stehen oder
plaintext
sonst wo...
Also ich sehe das
tatsächlich als gar nicht
so schlecht an, wenn ich mir das
zu Recht überlege.
Es hat aber ähnliche Schwachstellen
wie ein ordentlicher
Passwort-Manager, so nach dem Motto,
wenn ich Keylogger auf dem System habe
oder ein Rootkit auf dem System habe, was auch immer,
dann habe ich eh gelitten, dann kann ich auch
meine Private Keys abgesaugt werden.
Aber die Private Keys
und das Verfahren an sich ist
insgesamt schon sicherer, weil du
nicht mein Passwort 123456
hast
und weil du es nicht
so einfach leaken kannst.
Weil es eben ein schön integriertes
Verfahren ist. Ja, okay,
klingt an sich nicht verkehrt.
Notizzettel
am Monitor ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Das habe ich jetzt auch schon
öfters mal erzählt im Stream,
weil manche
sich immer darüber lustig machen, so Leute,
schreiben sich die Passwörter auf. Leute,
Passwörter auf einem Zettel ist gar nicht so
schlecht. Also, ganz im Ernst,
eine Passwort-TXT-Datei auf dem Desktop
ist schlechter, als ein Passwort-Zettel
im Schrank liegen zu haben.
Passwort-TXT auf dem Desktop ist weg,
sobald ihr euch mal ein bisschen Malware
eingefangen habt. Ein Passwort-Zettel
im Schrank, da kommt
kein Hacker-Man dran.
Natürlich, wenn ihr jetzt damit rechnet,
so nach dem Motto,
Leute, brechen bei euch ins Haus
ein, um euer Passwort-Zettel
zu entwenden. Ja gut, dann habt ihr Pech.
Da kommen dann wirklich so
Sachen wie irgendwelche Yubikeys
ins Spiel.
Einstöpseln, das Ganze digital gespeichert
und dann nur mit irgendeinem weiteren
Faktor, den man zur Freigabe
verwendet. Entweder nochmal
ein Master-Passwort, manches gibt es ja auch
so Dinge mit Fingerabdrücken und sowas.
Spätestens dann
haben alle Leute die Möglichkeit,
über alle ihre Geräte hinweg Passkeys
zu synchronisieren. Aber ihr müsst gar nicht
zwingend auf allen Geräten Passkeys
gespeichert haben. Eigentlich reicht das Smartphone
als digitaler Schlüssel. Das ist heute
der einfachste Weg, um Passkeys im Alltag
zu verwenden. Denn ihr könnt bei Diensten, die Passkeys
unterstützen, auswählen, dass ihr euer
Smartphone verwenden möchtet. Dann öffnet
ihr einfach die Kamera-App, scannt ein QR-Code
und der Login funktioniert über die gleiche
Technik. Was ist, wenn
mein Smartphone Schrott ist
und kaputt geht?
Die Kosten für Passkeys sind übrigens
gar nicht mal so hoch. Es reicht
ein aktuelleres iPhone mit iOS 16
also ab dem iPhone 8
oder wie gesagt ein Android-Smartphone
ab Version 9, ein Mac mit mindestens
macOS Ventura. Bei Windows
funktionieren Passkeys. Ja, weil man kann sagen,
ich will es ja eigentlich nicht in die Cloud sichern.
Und 11 über den eingebauten
Authentifizierungsdienst Windows Hello.
Wenn ihr hier das Smartphone verwenden wollt,
müsst ihr aktuell Chromium-basierte Browser
benutzen, also etwa Chrome Edge
oder Opera One. Richtig ins System
integriert soll diese Funktion erst mit einem
zukünftigen Update werden. Hier legt Microsoft
hoffentlich bald nach. Was ihr möglichst
tun solltet, nachdem ihr auf Passkeys bei
einem Anbieter umgestiegen seid, das
Passwort dort unbedingt entfernen.
Leider geht das aber bei weitem nicht bei allen Anbietern,
die heute schon Passkeys unterstützen.
Microsoft gehört zu den wenigen Anbietern, die
das heute schon können. Der NAS-Hersteller
Synology geht sogar einen Schritt
weiter und entfernt das Passwort nach einer
Vorwarnung automatisch, nachdem man dort
einen Passkey eingerichtet hat. Hat man
aber wirklich mal keinen Zugriff mehr
auf die Passkeys, also wenn euer Handy
vom Trecker überfahren ist,
kann man bei den Diensten wie schon
früher über die Recovery-Funktion wieder
Zugriff auf den Account bekommen.
Ganz klassisch über E-Mail oder SMS-Code.
Deswegen ist auch wichtig, egal
ob Passkey...
Ja gut.
Müssen sie ja irgendwie bieten, ja.
Nutzen oder nicht.
Und wie gesagt, Zugriff auf den
Account, ja. Zugriff auf
verschlüsselte Dateien, nein. Wenn das
funktioniert, macht der Anbieter irgendwelche
komischen Sachen.
Eine Liste mit allen Diensten,
die heute schon Passkeys unterstützen,
findet ihr unter www.passkeys.directory
Und wenn ihr euch jetzt fragt, wie kann
ich eigentlich selbst Passkeys in meine
Web-Apps integrieren, dann schaut euch mal
diesen CT-Artikel an.
Ich würde sagen, der Fiat Champ braucht
Passkeysupport, oder?
Hier gibt es auch noch ein CT-Interview mit dem
Executive Director der
Fido Alliance. Beide Artikel haben
wir euch unten in der Beschreibung verlinkt.
Mein Fazit. Passkeys sind
heute schon eine echte Alternative
zu bestehenden Passwörtern.
Wo sie halt schon angeboten werden. Klar, noch machen
da nicht alle mit. Und das heißt, im Moment
führt noch kein Weg um einen Passwortmanager
und so viel Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung
wie möglich herum. Aber
das könnte sich schon schnell ändern.
Microsoft und Google haben sich auf eine
passwortlose Zukunft verständigt und das
könnte einen großen Einfluss auf die Entwicklung
nehmen. Immerhin könnten Apple und Google einfach
sagen, alle Apps, die wir hier
App Store oder Google Play Store anbieten,
müssen Passkeys unterstützen.
Und dann würden schon in kurzer Zeit
sehr viele Dienste Passkeys unterstützen.
Ja, was denkt ihr? Benutzt ihr schon Passkeys?
Und wie sind eure Erfahrungen im Umgang
mit sicheren Passwörtern? Habt ihr überhaupt schon mal
von Passkeys vorher gehört? Schreibt es gerne
in die Kommentare und natürlich gerne
abonnieren. Tschüss!
Hast du eigentlich Bitcoin? Nee.
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Warum krieg ich so viele
CAC-W-Videos empfohlen, man?
Ich darf das Zeug nicht anklicken. Wenn ich
das anklicke, dann hört es überhaupt
nicht mehr auf. Ey, du!
Guck mal, es hört überhaupt nicht mehr auf.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Zig in 100 Sekunden Fireship.
Bester Mann.
Zig, a high-performance system programming
language, often labeled as a next
generation alternative to C...
Ich hab fast das gleiche, Chainlore.
It was created by Andrew Kelly
in 2016 and has quickly evolved
into one of the most desired new languages in the world.
Like C, it's minimal, extremely fast.
Haben wir im Stream sogar schon ausprobiert.
Ich war noch nicht so
hundertprozentig überzeugt.
Vor allem diese komische Pointer-Syntax.
Wie ging das nochmal so, gell?
Punkt, Sternchen,
Punkt. Das war irgendwie ein bisschen
gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Fast and allows for low-level memory control.
But instead of managing memory directly
in the language with functions like malloc
and free, the Zig standard library
ships allocators to provide a consistent
interface for memory management.
Zig is not a memory-safe language like Rust
or Go, but it doesn't have any hidden memory
allocations, making the code far more
explicit and portable, because allocators
can be easily swapped out in the code to target
different architectures, like x86,
ARM, WebAssembly and BareMetal.
In addition, Zig has no hidden control flow.
If it looks like a function...
Zig ist nicht BareMetal, oder was?
Ah! Ah!
C++-Vibes!
Dings, ähm,
Konstexpr und so Zeug. Hör mal auf!
Weiche,
Teufel, C++.
Haben wir ausprobiert?
Wir haben versucht
FFmpeg und Zig
zusammen zu verwenden. Hat funktioniert,
war aber ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Das hat mich auch verwirrt.
Nein, Fleisch!
Okay, so advanced shit haben wir mit Zig nicht gemacht.
In was haben wir Zig entwickelt?
Visual Studio Code, oder? Also die IDE-Experience
war auch noch nicht so geil.
Ha!
Testing.
Keck, wait.
Wer macht denn sowas?
Einfach keine Fehler programmieren.
Brauchen wir keine Tests.
Stimmt, Package Manager,
weiß ich gar nicht, haben wir das ausprobiert?
Ja, doch, natürlich haben wir das ausprobiert.
Package Manager war richtig eklig.
Wir mussten uns irgendwelche
Bild-Files
anpassen,
Library Include
oder sonst was
für einen Command-Line-Parser.
Das war eklig, das hat mir auch nicht gefallen.
Was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Was war denn das?
Erst 21 und schon Abteilungsleiter.
Gehalt als Event-Manager
im Hotel, lohnt sich das?
Ich hoffe mal, dass sich das lohnt.
Wo müssen die Big Stonks verdient werden?
Leute, ich muss mal ganz kurz
auf Klo.
Könnt ihr euch eine Runde Fische angucken?
Ich muss mal kurz eine Runde auf Klo.
Ich bin in zwei Minuten wieder da.
So, wieder da.
Stimmt, wo ist die Angel?
Wird hier nicht geangelt im ASCII-Aquarium?
Doch, da ist doch die Angel.
Ich kann sagen, ich habe die neueste und beste
ASCII-Aquarium-Version.
Okay, also wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Erst 21 und schon Abteilungsleiter.
Gehalt als Event-Manager.
Dann gucken wir uns das doch mal an,
ob sich das lohnt.
Heute Abend, hättest du da lieber lange Tafeln
oder sollen wir die Tische einzeln hinstellen?
Ich habe bewusst nach dem Hauptschulabschluss aufgehört.
Wir haben heute Abend hier einen Geburtstag.
Das ist Toss-Musik.
Also ich denke, dass ein bis zwei Mal im Jahr
eine Gehaltsverhandlung in Ordnung ist.
Da gebe ich ihm recht, ja.
Fragen ist das Beste, was man machen kann
und denen ein bisschen auf den Keks gehen.
Weil ansonsten hast du das Problem,
du wartest drei bis vier Jahre,
irgendwann kriegst du was
und stellst fest, du bist eigentlich
immer noch ein bisschen unter dem Durchschnitt
und dann heißt es, du hast doch erst was gekriegt.
Also für die eigene
Entwicklung ist es sinnvoll,
im Jahr mindestens einmal zu fragen.
Für mein Kind.
Hallo, ich bin Noah,
21 Jahre alt, aus Benrith
und Eventmanager im Hotel.
Weil er gerade gesagt hat, schon ein Kind mit 21.
Gut, manche sind schnell.
Ein Kollege von mir, mit dem ich in der Schule war,
der hat auch quasi
direkt mehr oder weniger
zum Schulabschluss
fast schon Vater geworden.
Der hat Abi gemacht und ist dann Vater geworden.
Mit einer aus der Schule.
Das war aber eher
unglücklich.
Die haben nicht aufgepasst.
Der ist irgendwie mit
keine Ahnung, der war
18,5 direkt Nachwuchs.
Moin.
Morgen.
Alles gut?
Wir gehen jetzt zum Abteilungsleiter-Briefing.
Das sehen wir morgen.
Abteilungsleiter-Briefing, das klingt ja schon mal richtig
wichtig.
Aber er hat schon mal die passende Manager-Uniform an.
Abteilungsleiter geworden bin.
Da war ich ein halbes Jahr
hier im Betrieb.
Abteilungsleiter mit vier Angestellten?
Was ist das für eine Abteilung?
Abteilungsleiter geworden bin.
Da war ich
ein halbes Jahr hier im Betrieb.
Moin.
Normalerweise hast du einen Abteilungsleiter.
Du hast dann
vielleicht vier Teams unter dir.
Das sind
70 Personen im Kamin-Restaurant.
Okay, vielleicht meinen die
das mit vier Teamleiter.
Das würde dann mehr Sinn ergeben.
Guck mal, die sind agil.
Das übernimmt die Xenia.
Das ist ihre Veranstaltung oben, sie ist auch da.
Die fangen an um 17 Uhr mit
einem Prosecco-Empfang, gehen dann über
in den Viergang und dann
feiern bis um 3 Uhr.
Der Lasitsch ist bis zum Ende da.
Die schwierigste Aufgabe ist, jeden Mitarbeiter
gut platzieren, gut einsetzen,
dass jeder weiß, was er machen soll.
Ja, und die richtigen Leute für die richtigen Jobs
haben.
An, wer ist wann da
zum Essen schicken, für die Bar,
für den Empfang vorzubereiten.
Einfach, dass man viele Hände hat,
die dann auch gut
eingesetzt sind.
Wir haben relativ oft
Prominente hier bei uns.
Wie viel?
Wir haben relativ oft...
Ach, Median-Hotel-Fach...
Okay.
Da würde ich erwarten, dass man als Abteilungsleiter
dort, unabhängig von dem, was man mal
gelernt hat, doch eine Ecke mehr bekommt.
Letzte Woche hat man zum Beispiel
Otto Weickes hier, der war im Buchheim-Museum.
Otto!
Für mich ist jeder Gast gleich.
Ich will ihm immer denselben Standard bieten.
Und ob das jetzt der
Verein aus Bernried ist oder
der FC Bayern München, da mache ich keinen Unterschied.
Also ich habe bewusst nach dem
Hauptschulabschluss...
Das glaube ich ihm nicht, dass er da keinen Unterschied macht.
Gibt's bestimmt noch mal eine Extra-Wurst.
Ich wusste sehr früh,
was ich wollte. Mit 14 habe ich mich damals entschieden,
ins Hotel zu gehen.
Jetzt steht mal wieder keiner am Arbeiten.
Ich suche jetzt
das Function-Sheet zu der Veranstaltung für heute Abend.
Die Bürostühle kommen mir sehr bekannt vor.
Ich glaube, die hatten wir beim alten Arbeitgeber auch.
Glücklicherweise hatte ich
dort den gleichen, den ich auch daheim hatte,
weil ich ja in der Nähe von
unserem Support-Center gehockt habe
und die hatten so 24-7-Schicht-
Stühle, da habe ich mir auch einen
gegönnt von.
Und dann gehe ich zu den Kellnern, wir besprechen dann
einmal, wie wir stehen, wo wir das Buffet aufbauen,
wie die
Bestuhlung ist.
Heute Abend? Hier links alles, oder?
Wie habt ihr das jetzt geplant?
Wir überlegen noch, ob wir die Tische
zusammenschieben oder einfach so lassen.
Weil wenn wir
die Tische zusammenschieben, ist das jetzt ein bisschen knapp.
Gut, danke.
Grüß dich, servus.
Du, heute Abend,
hättest du da lieber lange Tafeln?
Aber man sieht schon mal,
das scheint auch wieder ein Beruf zu sein, wo man
auch tatsächlich was arbeitet den Tag über.
Nicht wie diese
Excel-Schubser,
Unternehmensberaterin, die sie
da mal hatten.
Einfach ein bisschen verteilen
und dann, okay, okay.
Perfekt. Super, danke dir.
Also ich enge mich immer zu 100%
rein, wenn es sein muss, auch
zu 150%.
Ich habe kein Problem,
auch mal aufs Feiern gehen
oder die Freizeit am Abend
zu verzichten, wenn es für den Job ist.
Siehste?
Da sehen wir, das ist der High-Performer-Karriere-Grinder.
Bei mir wäre
da der Spaß
vorbei. Also ich kann
sicherlich mal, wenn mich jemand
fragt, so nach dem Motto, Max, Samstag
haben wir irgendwie wichtige Wartungsarbeiten
und das
im Vorfeld anfragt,
ob ich da dabei sein kann, da sage ich dann auch nicht
Nein, das klappt dann meistens.
Aber so dieses Selbstverständliche
und Regelmäßige, ach nö, dann mache ich das halt
mal länger und verzichte, das gibt es nicht.
Wir haben heute Abend hier
einen Geburtstag
mit 70 Personen.
Wir haben ein
Viergangmenü
und dann Party bis um 3.
Was haben die
für vereinbarter Mindestumsatz für 70 Personen?
Ja, okay,
mit 70 Personen, die fressen ja auch viel.
Ich meine, du kannst locker
ja, da kommst du hin, guck mal
was weiß ich
bei 50,
okay, ja,
das ist doch eigentlich, denke ich, ganz okay.
Wir haben ein Viergangmenü
und
dann Party bis um 3.
Sollen wir die Tische einmal alle noch mal
durchgehen?
Ob das passt mit den Namen?
Die Musik, was ist jetzt los?
Der Platz hier,
das ist ein Kinderplatz.
Bei den Kindern werden logischerweise die Bestecke
ausgedeckt. Das mittlere Besteck
bleibt immer liegen für
zum Beispiel ein paar Pommes oder einen Kinderschnitzel.
Weingläser
braucht das Kind meistens auch nicht.
Der Job kann definitiv
stressig sein. Wir haben Wochenenden
gehabt, da haben wir vier Veranstaltungen.
Ja, wir wären das auch zu viele Menschen, da hätte ich auch
keinen Bock drauf. Aber ihm scheint es ja zu gefallen.
Das ist ja die Hauptsache, muss jeder das finden, was
ihm passt. Gleichzeitig
standen wir erst vor zwei Wochen, glaube ich,
da waren es anstatt
70 Personen 140.
Und das wurde zwei Stunden vorher
mitgeteilt. Das haben wir dann auch
noch geschafft, aber sind alle gerannt wie blöde.
Warum fällt das denen
ein paar Stunden vorher ein? Ach übrigens,
ich habe mich mit 70 Leuten angemeldet,
aber ja, also
wahrscheinlich kommen 140.
Fuck.
Wir bieten den Gästen eine Rundfahrt
an. Die soll ungefähr 10 Minuten
dauern und wir fahren jetzt mal die Stellen ab.
Schauen, wo man halten kann,
was man sieht.
Das würde ich mir jetzt auch mit aufschreiben,
dass wir das Teehaus mit aufnehmen.
Da die Geschichten zu raussuchen.
Das ist auch immer erwähnenswert.
Und dann würde ich ganz gerne eine Stelle
tun, wo wir
anhalten, wo es schön ist,
wo man dann vielleicht eine Runde
Sekt ausgibt. Auf dem Boot?
Auf dem Boot.
Ja gut, das macht sich natürlich cool.
Da kommen sich die Leute so richtig Promi-mäßig vor.
Sekt auf dem Boot.
Beim Einparken ist aber so eine Sache.
Ich denke, da haben wir was Gutes gemacht. Wenn wir das noch ausarbeiten
mit den Geschichten
zu den Locations, dann ist das perfekt.
Gute Lunge.
16 Uhr gibt es mal
drei Pommes frites. Alter,
das kann doch nicht alles sein.
Wir haben eine Personalkantine,
aber wir haben jetzt oben heute eine Veranstaltung.
Da bereitet die Küche ein bisschen vor.
Deswegen variieren wir immer.
Es gibt ja viele schöne Plätze hier zum Essen.
Der ist satt mit einem
halben Teller Pommes frites mittags.
Da kriege ich erst richtig Hunger.
Wir wollen
jeden Gast glücklich machen.
Die Gäste lassen teilweise sehr viel Geld hier.
Warte, dein alter Arbeitgeber
auch ein Standard in Nürnberg.
Ich werde mich weder Pro noch Contra dazu äußern,
weil da kann man zu viel ableiten.
Immer die dementsprechende Leistung.
Hallo Herr Ralinger.
Wie geht es Ihnen?
Danke, sehr gut.
So weit fast alles?
Alles wunderbar. Vielen Dank für die tolle Organisation.
Schön, dass Sie da sind.
Man sieht immer in den Gesichtern der Gäste,
dass wenn sie lächeln, dann sind sie glücklich.
Es ist auch immer wichtig, dass alle ein bisschen zusammenstehen
dann läuft es einfach.
Dann sind die Leute glücklich.
Viel zu viele Leute auf einem Fleck für mich.
Wir müssen bei der Veranstaltung schauen,
dass die Sachen pünktlich und schnell rausgehen.
Dass jeder das bekommt, was er bestellt.
Dann müssen alle Abteilungen zusammenspielen.
Die Bar, der Service, die Küche.
Dass das gleichzeitig alles perfekt rausgeht.
Spargelors.
Würde ich mir jetzt auch
reindrücken, so ein paar Spargel und Schnitzel.
Mache dann Feierabend,
wenn alle Gäste und Kollegen zufrieden sind.
Brutto verdiene ich 3000 Euro.
Da kommen noch mal Zulagen im Monat drauf.
Das sind die Feiertage.
Hätte ich jetzt eigentlich ein bisschen mehr mit gerechnet.
Mein Typ macht so viel über Stunden,
ist so lange am Start.
Als Abteilungsleiter hätte ich jetzt ein bisschen mehr erwartet.
Sonntag- und Nachtzuschläge
sind dann netto
um die 2300 Euro.
Also ich denke,
dass ein bis zweimal im Jahr eine Gehaltsverhandlung
in Ordnung ist.
Geld ist mir vor allem wichtig für mein Kind.
Um da später dann eben auch mal
was bieten zu können.
Wir haben uns damals sehr jung schon
dazu entschieden.
Für mich wäre das überhaupt
gar nichts.
Da muss man den ganzen Tag mit anderen Leuten zusammenarbeiten.
Und gerade bei den Gästen
musst du dann auch nett sein zu denen.
Obwohl du denkst, das ist der Ultraspast.
Da hätte ich ja überhaupt
keinen Bock drauf.
Dass es eine schöne Aufgabe
wird und das hat sich auch definitiv
bestätigt.
Nebenbei betreibe ich
eine Eventfirma.
Plane verschiedene Tanzveranstaltungen.
Nebenbei? Heißt das am Wochenende
oder was? Wenn er den Tag über eh schon immer
Überstunden schaffen muss.
Krass. Ich sag dir, Kreisel-Kreisel-High-Performer-Mindset
haben wir hier vor uns.
Das ist unter anderem im Saustallclub.
Und da haben wir jetzt einen Termin mit dem Lichttechniker.
Weil wir ein neues Lichtprogramm bekommen haben.
Und das schauen wir uns jetzt einmal an.
Servus.
Wir haben jetzt
das Licht umgestellt.
Und ein Kind hat er auch noch.
Also der ist wirklich beschäftigt 24-7.
Altem Pult.
80 Stunden auf dem Computer.
Das hat Gott sei Dank der Markus
für mich übernommen, weil ich habe keine Ahnung davon.
Ich bin super zufrieden.
Es variiert aber extrem
von Monat zu Monat.
Also im Winter sehr viel.
Im Sommer dafür weniger.
20 Uhr.
Da sind wir teilweise noch schon 3 Stunden am Stream.
Ich zahle sehr wenig Miete.
Dafür, dass ich hier direkt am See wohne.
Ich habe Gott sei Dank nur 100 Meter runter.
Das ist natürlich auch dem geschuldet,
dass es eine Personalwohnung ist und der Arbeitgeber
da wesentlich weniger
verlangt, als was der Durchschnitt wäre.
Da sind wir teilweise weit über 1500 Euro.
Also der Job als Eventmanager
lohnt sich für mich definitiv.
Ich bin sehr glücklich mit dem, was ich mache.
Ich habe jeden Tag was Neues.
Er macht auch den Eindruck, als macht er das.
Das passt auch noch.
Oh!
Toss!
Toss-Musik.
So, also.
Was bleibt am Ende übrig?
Nichts.
95 Euro.
Toss-Toss-Toss-Toss.
Also ich hätte eigentlich gedacht,
dass man da als Abteil...
Alter, wie viele Keck-W-Videos
will man das Ganze noch empfehlen?
Dass man als Eventleiter,
Projektmanager, Abteilungsleiter...
Dass es ein bisschen mehr drin ist.
Schon gedacht.
Also die YouTube-Empfehlungen
sind wirklich absolut pp-iger.
Ey, es ist etwas
übertrieben, YouTube, mit den Videos.
Was? Webseite?
Superpower? Mit dem Javascript-Logo?
Ja.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch für...
Jetzt bewiesen. GitHub Copilot.
iPhone-Ausnahme.
Die EU knickt ein.
Ist das wirklich so?
Ich dachte, das Einzige,
was die EU vorgegeben hat, ist der Stecker.
Und Apple hat jetzt gesagt,
ja gut, äh...
Heißt ja nicht, dass man auch
schnelle Datenübertragung dann darüber machen kann.
Wenn es kein zertifiziertes Kabel ist.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal an,
warum die EU einknickt.
Portablen Spielekonsolen.
Das klingt eigentlich fast zu schön,
um wahr zu sein.
Austauschbare Akkus in allen Smartphones,
Tablets, Notebooks oder
Portablen Spielekonsolen.
Ach Moment. Austauschbare Akkus?
Ich dachte, es geht um USB-C.
Es geht um USB-C.
Es geht um Austauschbare Akkus.
Ach so. Oder wieder was ganz anderes.
Dann interessiert mich das doch nicht so sehr.
Das steckt im geilsten Gaming-PC,
den du gewinnen kannst.
Okay, ich will mir das Video nicht angucken.
Ich will nur wissen, was drinnen steckt.
Was steckt drinnen?
Eine Capture-Card. Okay.
4090, was sonst?
Okay.
Ein Ryzen-Dings hier.
X3D Edition.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das offiziell heißt.
Das sind explizit für Games.
Ordentlich viel RAM.
Ja, okay.
Also im Prinzip wahrscheinlich ungefähr das,
was ich hier auch stehen habe.
Alter, die Resitas-Videos.
Es ist gut, Alter.
Ich will keine...
YouTube sagt,
du musst es gucken.
I gave Website-Logo-Superpowers.
Okay.
Warum?
Das kann wackeln.
Coole Technik
unter 50 Dollar.
Wenn da ist nix dabei, was ich geil finde.
Okay, der hat seine Stimme krass
komprimiert, Kompressort.
Okay, auf geht's.
Wahrscheinlich werde ich alles Kacke finden.
Ich kann euch das jetzt schon sagen. Ihr kennt mich.
Ich bin bei sowas immer überkritisch.
Eine Lampe mit einer Lampe.
Eine Lampe mit einer Uhr oben drin.
Na toll.
Leute, ich habe überhaupt keine Tischlampe.
Ich brauche auch seit Jahren
keine Tischlampe mehr.
Ich habe zwei Dinger hier.
Ich habe mein Elgato Ringlicht.
Das benutze ich, wenn ich am Basteltisch
irgendwas basteln will.
Dann muss es richtig hell sein.
Oder ich benutze meine Deckenlampe,
die ich
per Smart Home einstellen kann.
Sowohl Farbtemperatur als auch Helligkeit.
Das reicht mir voll und ganz aus.
Ich wüsste nicht, wann ich zuletzt
eine Schreibtischlampe gebraucht habe.
Ja, aber
why?
Sehe ich keinen Sinn drin?
Ich will keinen Touch bei meiner
Schreibtischlampe haben.
Warum? Leute, das ist ein Trend,
den ich nicht nachvollziehen kann.
Warum Touch bei Sachen,
wo ein Knopf einfach viel
aussagekräftiger und ergonomischer wäre?
Warum muss es Touch sein?
Warum kein poplicher Knopf?
Guck mal, du weißt
überhaupt nicht, ob du richtig draufgedrückt hast.
Das ist so kacke.
Ich hasse so Touch-Controls
an den Stellen, wo es keinen Sinn macht.
Ein Knopf ist halt richtig gut.
Knopf weißt du, ich habe jetzt gedrückt.
Es funktioniert.
Okay, brauchen wir nicht.
Next.
Free Stream Deck.
Maus-Bungee-Pod.
Next.
Neue Tastatur-Keycaps.
Was ist das hier?
Ein Mini-Mischpult.
Brauche ich nicht.
Als Empfehlung.
Da habe ich mein Audio-Interface.
Super.
Mega-Poggers-Empfehlung.
Das hat richtig gelohnt, als wir uns das angeguckt haben.
Most Popular Programming Languages.
Das können wir uns mal angucken.
Zeig mal her.
Okay, es ist ohne.
Nee, doch mit Musik.
Da geht es ja schon gut los.
Gut, wir sind 1966.
Zweites Quartal.
Ist schon ein bisschen her.
APL.
Musik, ey.
Pascal, okay.
C gab es noch nicht.
C gibt es noch erst 1977.
Cobol Fortran.
Basic.
Mir war auch gar nicht so klar, dass es Basic
sogar schon vor C gab.
Aber jetzt im Nachhinein ergibt es Sinn.
Pascal ist die erste hiervon
halbwegs gut schreibbare, lesbare
Sprache.
Es gibt immer noch Anhänger von Lisp.
Ja, Lisp ist
der älteste überhaupt.
Es gibt ja immer noch relativ viele Anhänger, die
voll auf Lisp schwören.
Also Pascal
ist tatsächlich
das erste hiervon, was man sich halbwegs geben kann.
Vielleicht noch Basic, wenn es sein muss.
Aber Pascal ist ganz okay.
C, jawoll.
Jetzt kommt endlich mal was Gescheites.
Guck mal.
Seit 1977 war Cobol
schon Legacy-Technologie.
Ah ne, ich meinte Cobol.
Jetzt geht es bergab mit Cobol.
C.
Und Pascal geht durch die Decke.
Pascal war eine
Zeit lang ultra beliebt.
Jetzt kommt C++.
Leider.
Moment, wann war das Jahr?
Okay, 1981.
Also sollte mal
irgendjemand eine Zeitmaschine erfinden.
Wir müssen das Jahr 1981 zurück
irgendwie verhindern, dass C++ erfunden wird.
C, jawoll.
Beste, gib ihm.
Ada. Dass das mal so
verbreitet war, wusste ich gar nicht.
Dachte, das war so ein Ding,
was mal da war und niemand mehr jetzt benutzen möchte.
Wir erfinden
einfach direkt Rust 1981.
Perfekte Idee, Leute.
C auf der Überholspur.
Pascal weg,
Lisp weg, C++
dazu noch. Na gut.
Oh Gott, C++.
Ja, C++
gräbt halt Pascal und Ada
irgendwie den Rang
ab.
Oh, Visual Basic 1992.
Oh.
Jetzt kommt doch
bald Java irgendwann, gell?
Dauert doch gar nicht mehr so lange.
Java ist doch auch recht alt.
Oh.
Perl.
Was ist die Einheit? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Prozent an Verbreitung?
Prozentuale Verbreitung?
Aber nee, wir kommen hier
auf mehr als 100%.
Ja, dann weiß ich's auch nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was die Einheit ist.
Sieht aber gut aus.
Guck mal, da hat sich jetzt in der Schule
schon jemand beschwert, wenn hier die Achsen
nicht beschriftigt sind.
Javascript! Endlich!
Jetzt ist es soweit. Wir sind gerettet.
Javascript hat das Licht der Welt erblickt.
Googlesuche in 1000?
Ich glaube nicht, dass 1966
jemand mit Google schon was gesucht hat.
Java.
Gib ihm.
Jawohl.
Ja, das war die Zeit.
Das war die Zeit von Webentwicklung
und PHP.
Ja.
Endlich eine gescheite Sprache hier drauf.
Aufgeploppt.
Ruby!
Ja, hier ein bisschen
so in dem Dreh hat das
angefangen mit Ruby on Rails.
So 2006 rum.
Oder noch früher. Ruby on Rails ist alt.
Ruby on Rails
Release Date
2004, ja.
Ruby ist eine mega gute Sprache.
Ich finde immer noch,
rein von den Sprachen, wenn mich
einer fragen will, so Max, welche Sprache
gefällt dir so von Syntax,
Handhabung und allem insgesamt
am besten, würde ich sagen tatsächlich
es ist Ruby und C Sharp.
Ruby ist so eine nice Sprache.
Leider hat sich
Ruby nie außerhalb von Rails
großartig durchgesetzt.
Was schade ist, Ruby ist
wirklich eine super Sprache.
Also ich persönlich würde eindeutig
Ruby bevorzugen versus Python, allerdings
rein aus Sicht
von Verbreitung,
Ökosystem und
Wiederverwendbarkeit und sonst was
würde ich heute auch eher
was in Python machen als in Ruby, wenn ich
was hätte, wofür sich die Sprache eignet.
Weil, ganz im Ernst,
Python ist richtig groß
im Science-Bereich,
an Unis, im Machine Learning,
kannst du mit Ruby alles knicken.
Es dauert auch nicht mehr lang, bis es Go gibt.
Ich glaube die erste Go-Version
gab es 2009 oder sowas.
Aber Leute, wir wissen alle,
was jetzt passieren wird gleich, oder?
JavaScript wird Nummer 1.
Also müsste bald losgehen.
JavaScript überholt alles.
Würde ich zumindest ganz stark davon ausgehen,
dass es jetzt kommt, und zwar mit Abstand.
Nein, Crystal basiert nicht
auf Ruby. Crystal ist
inspiriert
von Ruby. Crystal sagt auch selbst,
dass es kein Ziel
ist, kompatibel zu Ruby zu sein.
Und ich glaube
Crystal funktioniert unter Windows
immer noch nicht. Swift!
Jetzt geht JavaScript
durch die Decke.
Web 7.0
C Sharp hat rechtmäßigen
Platz hier vorne. Python, Machine Learning
so in den Anklängen
anfangen vielleicht jetzt.
Und im Science-Bereich,
ich meine, im Prinzip ist es
Python und JavaScript. Die werden vorne landen.
Das wissen wir ja schon.
Typescript, okay.
Die wollen wir nicht ernsthaft erzählen.
Na gut, wenn nur Typescript und JavaScript
dabei sind. Die wollen wir nicht ernsthaft erzählen,
weil Python so viel für JavaScript ist.
JavaScript ist auch in allen
Stackoverflow-Umfragen und sowas immer
das meistgefragteste und meistbenutzte
und überhaupt. Natürlich ist Python
vorne mit dabei. Vielleicht bei Google-Anfragen
oder was auch immer die Datengrundlage ist.
Aber bei der Verbreitung
insgesamt dürfte JavaScript einfach
meilenweit vorne sein. Vor allem.
Oh, Rust ist auch am Start. Nice.
Ja, das muss, Leute,
das muss Google-Anfragen sein.
Weil von der Verbreitung her
ach, popular. Ja, es
müssen so eine Art Google-Anfragen sein.
Ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo man Google als Metric
nehmen kann, davor irgendwas Historisches.
Weil Rust ist nie im Leben
in den Top Ten
der meistbenutzten Sprachen drin.
Wenn man das mal,
ist es auf GitHub sehr beliebt,
es ist popular ohne Ende, aber im Leben
nicht in den Top Ten meistbenutzten
Technologien.
Wie viele sind es? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8, 9, 10. Ja.
Was ist denn die Datengrundlage?
Man weiß es nicht.
Es gibt keinen Link zur Statistik.
Dann können wir
das jetzt klauen
oder auch sein lassen.
Man weiß es ja nicht.
Es gab ja keinen Link zur Statistik.
Ja, genau. Datasource.
Das habe ich gelesen, aber die haben
ein bisschen mehr als eine Statistik.
Ach, was auch immer.
Ich glaube, Python dürfte bei
Stackoverflow ganz vorne mit dabei sein,
was Fragen angeht.
Dadurch, dass es auch sehr viele Leute als Einstiegssprache
benutzen, dürfte es ziemlich weit
vorne sein. Keine Ahnung.
Was sagt er denn aktuell?
Python C,
C++, ja.
Und in JavaScript...
Es ist halt bescheuert, ey.
Das ist ja verkaufte Programmierbücher
und sowas. Dass Python da vorne ist,
wundert mich nicht. Das ist so die Einsteigersprache
schlechthin. Aber von der Verwendung
insgesamt... Ich meine, überlegt euch nochmal.
80% des Tages, die Leute benutzen
einen Browser für Sachen. Das JavaScript
ist 100% auf Platz 1,
wenn es um die Verbreitung geht.
Wir können da sogar mal
TypeScript noch dabei rechnen,
dann noch weiter vorne.
Guck mal, auf Platz 7 ist
fucking Visual Basic. Warum
zum Teufel ist Visual Basic auf
Platz 6 und Platz 7?
Äh, der Index ist richtig
bescheuert. Excel?
Nee, Excel war da nicht drin.
Ach, du meinst zum Excel
automatisieren? Quatsch.
Das ist doch eklig.
Chat, was haltet ihr davon, wenn wir
nachher weiter den Frontend-Champ bauen?
Heute Nachmittag irgendwann.
Gestern waren wir
richtig produktiv.
Gestern ging richtig gut, ne?
Ich gucke immer mal
ganz gerne
bei mir auf dem Channel, was die Leute
so clippen.
Ich hab gestern auch gar nicht geguckt.
Wat?
Nee, das kann...
Twitch ist kaputt, kann das sein?
Achso, featured clips
only. Ja, was auch immer.
Ein nicer Frontend-Hacker-Man
wurde geklippt. Okay.
Was wurde da geklippt?
Ganz, ganz gering...
Ja, ganz geringverdiener.
Hör sich mal hier an.
Application...
Okay, alles klar.
Das haben die Leute geklippt.
Muss ja wissen, was die Leute
gerne gucken.
Noctua-Fans.
Ayayaspeak.
Beruf des Monats.
Elektroniker für Automatisierungstechnik.
So Leute, ich geh jetzt was essen.
Wir sehen uns heute Mittag.
Wenn wir weiter
Lachsnudeln.
Ja, Nudeln mit Lachs
heute.
Letztes Wochenende gab's schon was anderes.
Wird mal langsam wieder Zeit für traditionelle
Max-FPS-Sonntagsessen.
Da wird der Lachs rausgeholt.
Genau.
Ich weiß, es wird irgendwann noch ein Nachmittag.
Alles klar, bis dann. Wir sehen uns.
See you.